mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer nos travaux pour des examens
du PLF 2023 avec tout d'abord la mission
enseignement scolaire donc nous
accueillons le ministre de l'éducation
et de la jeunesse pour cette première
audition budgétaire de la législature il
est vrai que c'est un moment un peu
particulier puisque nous sommes tous
rivés sur nos téléphones ou presque et
sur la séance donc à tout moment je peux
prononcer une suspension de séances pour
que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
puisse rejoindre l'hémicycle si
nécessaire notre commission a désigné
deux rapporteurs pour avis sur la
mission enseignement scolaire Monsieur
Philippe fait et Christ et Monsieur
Christophe Marion donc la partie
budgétaire de leur projet de rapport
pour avis a été adressé hier aux membres
de la commission et je les remercie pour
le travail d'audition et d'analyse
qu'ils ont réalisé comme le bureau de la
commission à la souhaitée ils ont
consacré la plus grande partie de leurs
travaux à un thème qu'ils ont choisi le
rôle de la formation initial et continue
dans l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant nous accueillons aussi
monsieur robar Reda le rapporteur
spécial de cette mission
donc l'organisation de nos débats sera
la suivante après la présentation des
crédits de la mission par monsieur le
ministre je donnerai la rapporte je
donnerai la parole au rapporteur pour
avis 5 minutes chacun aurait porteur
spécial 5 minutes puis aux orateurs des
groupes 4 minutes chacun et enfin la
parole sera au ministre pour une réponse
globale à ces interventions ensuite la
parole sera au commissaire qui le
souhaitent pour poser une question en
une minute et le ministre y répondra
puis ensuite si nous avons encore du
temps nous amènerons nous examinerons
les amendements et votre rond sur les
crédits après le départ de Monsieur le
Ministre donc monsieur le ministre je
vous laisse la parole
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés
ce projet de loi de finances le premier
de ce nouveau quinquennat et de cette
législature est un marqueur de notre
ambition en matière d'éducation il
traduit les ambitions du président de la
République pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'est-à-dire un projet
d'investissement massif et sans
précédent dans l'enseignement scolaire
au service des élèves et pour préparer
l'avenir de la nation le projet de loi
de finance pour 2023 propose donc une
augmentation inédite du budget de
l'Éducation nationale une progression
qui s'inscrit dans une dynamique de
croissance constante depuis 2017 puisque
lors du précédent quinquennat le budget
de l'Éducation nationale a progressé de
13% passant de 48,8 milliards en 2017
hors contribution des pensions de l'État
à 55,2 milliards en 2021 mais le budget
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui constitue
une réelle rupture dans l'ampleur de
l'augmentation budgétaire proposée le
PLF 2023 vise en effet un budget à
59,7 milliards d'euros pour l'éducation
nationale ce sont donc 3,7 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires soit une
croissance de
6,5% par rapport à 2022 c'est
considérable et inédit j'insiste sur ce
point
ce budget permet donc de mettre en
musique les priorités que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'énoncer que l'on peut
organiser autour de 5 axes d'abord la
revalorisation des enseignants ensuite
la réussite de tous les élèves
après l'école inclusive la lutte contre
les inégalités et enfin la possibilité
pour les équipes éducatives de mener des
projets pédagogiques innovants répondant
aux besoins des élèves
le premier axe donc celui de la
revalorisation et bien entendu celui qui
compte le plus dans le budget 2023 c'est
une revalorisation indispensable à toute
action de refondation et de
transformation de l'école
il s'agit à la fois de reconnaître
l'engagement des enseignants au service
de leurs élèves et partant de leur pays
trop souvent reconnaissons que cette
engagement n'a pas été toujours
récompensés à sa juste valeur il s'agit
aussi d'une question de niveau de vie il
s'agit aussi d'une reconnaissance d'un
marqueur indispensable de considération
de respect de soutien pour ces agents
publics qui apportent à la société
je n'ai pas besoin d'insister sur les
difficultés de recrutement que nous
avons cet effort a été amorcé par
mon prédécesseur Jean-Michel Blanquer
depuis 2017 notamment dans le cadre du
Grenelle de l'éducation le projet de loi
de finances 2023 traduit toutefois une
ambition nouvelle
la revalorisation des enseignants
représente une enveloppe totale de
1,135 milliards pour 2023 c'est d'autant
plus considérable qu'elle entrera en
vigueur en septembre 2023 au 1er
septembre et quel est donc
budgétée sur quatre mois de cette
revalorisation au titre du projet de loi
de finance 2023 cette revalorisation
elle est composée de deux parties il y a
d'abord une partie inconditionnelle et
une partie pacte perçue à la condition
de l'exercice de nouvelles missions qui
seront définies dans le cadre des
concertations que nous avons
ouvert avec les organisations syndicales
le 3 octobre dernier
pour ce qui concerne la partie
inconditionnelle
celle-ci dispose d'une enveloppe de 635
millions au PLF 2023 ce qui représente
1,9 milliards en année pleine
concentré sur la première partie de
carrière sur les 20 premières années de
la carrière l'objectif est de casser le
faux plat qui caractérise la progression
de salaire sur cette période cette
enveloppe prolonge l'effort fait dans le
cadre du Grenelle de l'éducation il a
hausse du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires pour aboutir à une hausse
totalement moyenne de 10%
cette hausse permettra notamment de
réaliser la promesse du président de la
République de ne plus avoir de nouveaux
enseignants payés moins de 2000 euros
net par mois
si la situation des nouveaux arrivants
impose de concentrer nos efforts sur la
première partie de carrière les
personnels situés en fin de carrière ne
sont pas oubliés les forces sera fait à
travers l'amélioration de l'accès au
grade finaux le hors classe et la classe
exceptionnelle dans le cadre de mesures
interministérielles qui sont
actuellement en discussion
par ailleurs la revalorisation passera
aussi comme je l'indiquais par un
nouveau pacte proposé à tous les
enseignants qui offrira une hausse
supplémentaire de rémunération à la
condition d'exercer de nouvelles
missions qui sont d'ailleurs parfois
réalisées
déjà réalisé sans être pleinement
valorisé
sans préjugés des conditions et des
conclusions de la concertation la
formation hors temps d'enseignement la
mise en oeuvre de projets pédagogiques
le suivi individualisé des élèves l'aide
à l'orientation ou encore le
remplacement de courte durée font partie
des missions qui pourraient faire
l'objet de ces rémunérations
supplémentaires
additionner à la part inconditionnel la
revalorisation totale pourra ainsi être
portée à 20% pour les enseignants
volontaires ce dispositif là conditionné
et doté d'une enveloppe de 300 millions
d'euros sur les quatre derniers mois de
2023 l'équivalent en année pleine à
compter de 2024 évoluera en fonction du
rythme des adhésions opaques
l'ensemble des enseignants y compris
ceux des lycées professionnels
bénéficieront de ces revalorisations par
ailleurs d'autres professionnels de
l'éducation nationale or enseignant
pourront aussi bénéficier de mesures
catégorielles les enjeux d'attractivité
et de reconnaissance peuvent en effet
également toucher ces autres catégories
ainsi la prime REP plus sera étendue à
des personnels qui ne la touchaient pas
jusqu'à présent tel que les aesh et les
AED F pour une enveloppe totale de 74
millions d'euros en outre d'autres
d'autres personnels bénéficieront de
revalorisation spécifique en particulier
les personnels de la filière
médico-sociale les personnels
administratifs ou les conseillers
pédagogiques une enveloppe de près de 66
millions d'euros sera ainsi mobilisé
pour l'ensemble de ces mesures
catégorielles
le deuxième axe fort de ce budget c'est
la réussite de tous les élèves cette
budgétairement cette priorité se traduit
principalement par deux actions en
premier lieu nous entendons poursuivre
l'amélioration du taux d'encadrement
dans le premier degré et le stabiliser
dans le second degré en second lieu nous
souhaitons prolonger et engager des
dispositifs pour la réussite des élèves
tels que les dédoublements en Rep le
plafonnement à 24 des classes de
primaire hors REP ou le développement
des classes Ulysse
cela je le conçois peut paraître
antinomique avec le schéma d'emploi
négatif en réaliser en réalité nous
faisons face à l'accentuation d'un
mouvement démographique déjà constaté
qui nous amène à perdre et en rythme
accéléré des élèves à chaque rentrée
scolaire
je rappelle que en disant la le taux de
natalité passait de 830000 naissances le
nombre de naissances de 830 000 par an à
738000 ce qui est considérable nous
avons donc eu sur le dernier quinquennat
une baisse de 300 000 élèves cette
baisse va s'accentuer pour ce
quinquennat si sur un rythme de 100 000
élèves par an pour un total de 500 000
élèves en moins attendus sur la période
2022 2027 cette évolution se traduit par
la diminution constatée de 58 000 élèves
à la rentrée 2022 une démission un tout
petit peu moins importante que ce que
nous prévoyons à quelques mois mais il
faut compter avec les 19.000 élèves
Ukrainiens qui sont venus renforcer nos
effectifs
mais les prévisions pour l'année
scolaire 2023 2024 atteignent presque
entre 95 000 et 100 000 élèves en moins
si nous devions répercuter complètement
cette baisse sur le nombre d'enseignants
cela reviendrait à supprimer
5000 postes d'enseignants en limitant
cette baisse à 2000 postes nous
poursuivons l'effort sur les taux
d'encadrement dans le premier degré qui
est notre priorité en la matière nous
sommes passés d'une moyenne de 23,6
enfants par classe en 2016 à 21,6 en
2022 et nous prévoyons de faire baisser
ce chiffre en 2023 pour atteindre 21,3
élèves par classe en moyenne
au-delà des dispositions budgétaires du
PLF la réussite des élèves passera par
des réformes structurantes comme celle
du collège sur laquelle nous travaillons
activement il s'agit aussi de la réforme
de la voix professionnelle annoncée par
le président de la République qui a
souhaité que celle-ci se construisent
dans le cadre d'une large concertation
menée par la ministre délégué
certains amendements font écho à la
crainte selon laquelle cette réforme
remettrait en cause l'acquisition des
fondamentaux avec ma collègue Carole
Grangeon nous nous assurerons que soit
trouver une voie qui permette en même
temps l'acquisition de connaissances
générales et l'amélioration de
l'insertion des élèves des lycées
professionnels dans le marché du travail
concernant cette réforme le PLF 2023 ne
retranscrit pas des orientations qui
seront prises à l'issue de cette phase
de concertation dès vendredi 4 groupes
de travail associant tous les acteurs
vont être lancés
le troisième point c'est la poursuite de
l'école inclusive puisqu'elle demeure
plus que jamais une priorité pour mon
ministère et pour le gouvernement 4000
postes d'aesh ont été créés à la rentrée
2023 après une hausse identique en 2022
vos propositions d'amendement font
apparaître une préoccupation légitime
sur la situation financière des aesh la
revalorisation la déprécarisation qui
sont autant d'objectifs que je partage
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
sur ce sujet je tiens néanmoins à
souligner que l'avenir de cette
profession doit s'inscrire dans le cadre
d'une réflexion plus globale sur l'école
inclusive en travaillant sur la
diversité des formes d'accompagnement en
rénovant aussi les modalités de
notification et en mettant au centre
l'évaluation des besoins des élèves en
situation de handicap des concertations
en ce sens ont été engagées suite au
comité
ministériel sur le handicap qui s'est
tenu le 8 octobre dernier
concertation qui nous permettront
d'avancer vers des évolutions plus
profondes nous travaillons dès à présent
néanmoins sur l'amélioration des
conditions de rémunération des ESH je
l'ai évoqué les ash bénéficieront
désormais des primes d'exercices en
repérer plus ce qui représente en 2023
une enveloppe de 43 millions la
revalorisation de leur rémunération de
la rémunération de ces personnels
passent également par une progression de
leur temps de travail avec l'objectif de
proposer à tous les aesh qui le
souhaitent
cela représentera un gain substantiel de
revenus pour ces personnels si
essentiels à la réussite de tous nos
élèves
ce chantier suppose une réflexion
d'ensemble sur les rôles des absh et
leur mission que nous venons d'engager
le quatrième point c'est la priorité en
matière de lutte contre les inégalités
c'est une un point important qui est au
fondement de notre capacité à faire
société c'est aussi une condition du bon
fonctionnement de l'éducation nationale
et de l'amélioration globale de nos
résultats pour cela nous disposons nous
développons les dispositifs de soutien
aux familles les plus fragiles via la
hausse des bourses qui a été annoncée
plus 4% dès la rentrée 2022 ce qui
représente 835 millions en 2023 nous
encourageons par ailleurs très fortement
les établissements à utiliser et à
améliorer l'utilisation de leur fonds
sociaux qui sont actuellement sous
consommés
la mise à disposition de petits
déjeuners gratuits à l'école sera
amplifié une enveloppe en forte hausse
et consacrée à ce dispositif pour un
total de 21,3 millions du fait de la
croissance du nombre d'établissements
s'inscrivant dans ce dispositif
enfin je suis très vigilant à propos des
inégalités territoriales en ce sens
l'expérimentation des contrats locaux
d'accompagnement et des territoires
éducatifs ruraux sera étendu près de 9
millions d'euros sont inscrits au PLF
2023 sur ces deux dispositifs qui
complètent la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire
par ailleurs la baisse des effectifs
enseignants tiendra bien sûr compte des
enjeux liés à la ruralité en conformité
avec l'engagement du président de la
République aucune fermeture d'école
n'interviendra sans l'accord des mères
l'enjeu de la mixité sociale est
également essentiel pour la réussite des
élèves les plus défavorisés et
l'ouverture vers des parcours plus
diversifiés en ce sens nous poursuivons
la création de section internationale en
éducation prioritaire pour faire de ces
établissements des centres attractifs le
cinquième et le dernier axe
consiste à donner à aux équipes
éducatives qui le souhaitent des moyens
pour construire des projets pédagogiques
innovants ces moyens vous le savez sont
inclus dans le fond d'innovation
pédagogique annoncé par le président de
la République dans une optique de
généralisation
de l'expérience de Marseille en grand
se font à vocation à financer des paix
projets pédagogiques innovants qui
s'inscrivent dans la continuité des
projets d'établissement les projets qui
bénéficient d'un soutien financier
pourront être très divers dès lors qu'il
vise à améliorer la réussite des élèves
ils pourront se rapporter à tout ou
partie des trois dimensions fondatrices
de la politique éducative l'élévation du
niveau de tous les élèves la réduction
des inégalités et le bien-être des
élèves et je me réjouis de ce point de
vue de voir que plusieurs centaines
d'établissements depuis deux semaines se
sont lancés dans ces concertations il
s'agit mesdames et messieurs d'une
rupture fondamentale dans la méthode
dans la déconcentration totale du
financement et une réponse rapide au
projet issus du terrain le front le
front d'innovation pédagogique permettra
par exemple comme le propose certains de
vos amendements de financer du matériel
adapté aux élèves cette situation de
handicap des projets culturels
environnementaux ou centrés sur des
méthodes innovantes d'apprentissage des
savoirs fondamentaux
ce font donc sera doté de 500 millions
d'euros sur la durée du quinquennat et
de 150 millions dès l'année 2023 il
s'agit d'un montant considérable qui
permettra à toutes les équipes qui
souhaitent s'engager dans cette démarche
dans ses projets innovants
et répondant aux dimensions que j'ai
citées à l'instant d'être soutenu
financièrement je suis certain qu'avec
ce fond en faisant confiance aux
communautés éducatives dans les écoles
et dans les établissements en leur
permettant de construire des projets aux
besoins qu'ils identifient nous
parviendrons à transformer l'école au
bénéfice de la réussite de tous les
élèves en 2023 les crédits du fond
d'innovation pédagogique seront
mobilisés à partir de la mission
investir pour la France de 2030 voilà
pour cette exposé madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
messieurs les rapporteurs les
principales lignes de force du budget
2023 qui représente je le répète un
effort inédit
de notre pays en faveur de ses élèves et
de ses enseignants je vous remercie de
votre attention et je suis à votre
disposition
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
ses propos et se balayage budgétaire
mais mes collègues ne manqueront pas de
vous interroger plus précisément sur
l'une ou l'autre des sur l'un ou l'autre
des axes que vous avez évoqué maintenant
je vais laisser la parole à nos
rapporteurs pour avis 10 minutes en tout
donc je ne sais pas qui commence
monsieur fait qui commence
chers collègues
le budget que le ministre vient de nous
présenter le premier budget de ce
quinquennat témoigne de l'ambition forte
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
faire de l'école le lieu de
l'instruction et de la Russie de tous
les élèves après deux années marquées
par la crise sanitaire la dernière
rentrée scolaire a suscité des
inquiétudes renouvelées en raison du
manque annoncé d'enseignant nous
constatons comme cela nous a d'ailleurs
été indiqué dans la plupart des
auditions que nous avons menées que les
services académiques ont mené un travail
remarquable tout au long de l'été et que
la rentrée de manière générale c'est
bien passée malgré le plus faible nombre
de candidats au concours d'enseignants
le taux d'encadrement de nos élèves
reste élevés et augmente même dans le
premier degré pour cette rentrée
scolaire
pour faire face cependant à la crise
structurelle et non uniquement
conjoncturel que connaît le métier
d'enseignant le gouvernement annonçait
des mesures inédites de revalorisation
salariale qui connaissent une traduction
effective dans le budget 2023 au-delà du
solaire d'autres éléments de réponse
sont apportés par ce projet de loi de
finance pour améliorer l'attractivité du
métier le développement des contrats de
prêt professionnels de constituer un
vivier précoce d'étudiants intéressés
par ces carrières la hausse des crédits
d'action sociale à destination des
personnels ou encore l'initiative plus
grande laissée aux équipes pédagogiques
pour construire des projets au travers
du Fonds d'innovation pédagogique sont
des exemples sur lesquels nous pourrons
revenir
avec mon collègue Christophe Marion nous
avons également souhaité nous attarder
sur un aspect que nous percevons comme
un véritable levier d'attractivité et de
valorisation du métier celui de la
formation initiale et continue
concernant plus particulièrement le
budget nous saluons l'augmentation
importante que connaît la mission
enseignement scolaire de plus de 6 % en
autorisation d'engagement et crédit de
paiement pour atteindre 82000 plus de 80
milliards d'euros contribution aux
pensions de l'État incluse augmentation
qui touche l'ensemble des six programmes
cette augmentation pour une mission dont
plus de 90% des crédits concernent de la
masse salariale est en grande majorité
portée par les revolver les
revalorisations annoncées au 1,7
milliards d'euros pour la hausse du
point d'indice de la fonction publique
s'ajoute 635 millions d'euros destinés à
garantir qu'aucun enseignant ne démarre
sa carrière en dessous de 2000 euros net
mais aussi à permettre la redynamisation
globale des parcours à partir de la
rentrée 2023 selon des modalités à
définir par la concertation
300 millions d'euros supplémentaires
seront liés à l'exercice des missions
complémentaires au travers du pacte avec
les enseignants ce montant à ce stade
qu'indicatif et de présageant pas
l'adhésion des enseignants Audi Pact le
contenu précis de ces missions nouvelles
et les modalités de mise en œuvre du
pack feront également l'objet de
concertation au résultat desquels nous
serons très attentifs en parallèle nous
notons que le schéma d'emploi diminue
d'environ 2100 postes d'enseignants -
1117 dans le premier degré et 481 dans
le second degré et -502 dans
l'enseignement privé soit
0,19% de l'ensemble des postes du
ministère cette diminution s'opère
cependant dans un contexte de très forte
baisse démographique et n'affectera pas
le taux d'encadrement des élèves lequel
continue à s'améliorer pour le premier
degré et se stabilise pour le second
degré
le temps nous manque pour entrer dans le
détail de chacun des programmes de la
mission et le ministre en a déjà dit
beaucoup avant nous mais nous
souhaitions revenir sur certains grands
axes qui nous semblent essentiels ce
budget permet d'abord de poursuivre de
prolonger le dispositifs relatifs à
l'égalité des chances ainsi le programme
140 enseignements scolaire public du 1er
degré prévoit que 1670 emplois seront
consacrés à la poursuite du dldoublement
des classes de grandes sections en
éducation prioritaire nous nous
enjouissons les dispositifs décorés de
la réussite des contrats locaux
d'accompagnement et des territoires
éducatifs ruraux sont également
prolongés pour un montant global
d'environ 13 millions d'euros nous
saluons également l'extension de la
prime allouée au personnel exerçant en
éducation prioritaire au-delà des seuls
enseignants pour un montant de 74
millions d'euros par ailleurs l'ambition
de l'école réellement inclusive ce
matérialise par une augmentation très
importante de 11,38% des crédits
consacrés à l'inclusion scolaire des
élèves en situation de handicap au sein
du programme de 130 vie scolaire
ces crédit permettront le recrutement à
la rentrée scolaire 2023 de 4000 aesh
supplémentaires recrutés sur le titre de
la création de 300 nouveaux dispositifs
Ulysse à la rentrée 2023 est également
prévue enfin nous notons la large place
faite à l'innovation pour avancer vers
une école du futur qui profite à tous
celle-ci se traduira au collège par des
expérimentations autour de la classe de
6e classe charnière silandé mais aussi
de la pratique sportive ou encore de la
découverte professionnelle en parallèle
150 millions d'euros seront consacrés au
fond d'innovation pédagogique et auront
vocation à financer tous les projets
novateurs proposés directement par les
établissements scolaires dès lors qu'il
présenteront un contenu pédagogique fort
ces crédits ne sont pas inscrits sur la
mission enseignement scolaire mais sur
la mission investir pour la France de
2030 ils seront débloqués et alloués en
fonction de l'émergence des projets
merci monsieur le député monsieur Marion
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
après cette partie budgétaire nous avons
souhaité approfondir notre étude sur un
levier d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant trop souvent sous-estimé
celui de la formation initiale et
continue dans ces deux domaines des
réformes importantes ont été menées ces
dernières années ont porté certains
fruits mais des difficultés persistent
qui doivent pouvoir être levés
informations initiale a été marquée
depuis la session 2022 par le
déplacement des concours de recrutement
du CAPES et du CRPE en fin de deuxième
année de master loin d'être une mesure
isolée cette évolution s'est inscrite
dans une série de modifications que nous
saluons l'évolution des maquettes de
formation et des concours davantage
tournés vers les compétences
professionnelles le développement de
l'alternance en Master 2 ou encore
l'élaboration de parcours préparatoires
ou de prêts professionnels dès la
première ou la deuxième année de licence
ces dispositifs permettent de constituer
un vivier d'étudiants intéressés par les
métiers d'éducation dès la fin du lycée
et de les fidéliser et de les
accompagner en sécurisant leur parcours
de formation sur cinq ans l'accent porté
sur la pratique professionnelle
l'observation et la mise en
responsabilité progressive doit garantir
de confronter les étudiants de manière
précoce aux réalités du terrain et de la
profession à laquelle ils aspire de
manière à prévenir les désillusions qui
pouvaient auparavant intervenir en toute
fin de parcours ou dans les premières
années de la carrière il n'en teneur il
n'en demeure pas moins que des
difficultés persistent qui tiennent à la
multiplicité des parcours et alors
faible visibilité sur parcoursup ce qui
peut nuire à leur attractivité mais
aussi au manque de place disponibles
pour les étudiants en master métier de
l'enseignement de l'éducation et de la
formation les fameux master MEF
souhaitant réaliser une alternance ou
encore à la charge de travail
importantes en Master 2 les
organisations syndicales évoquent aussi
pour certaines un contenu de la
formation initiale encore en décalage
avec les réalités du terrain des
ergistes des ajustements peuvent être
proposés sur ces points sans engager une
nouvelle réforme de grande ampleur que
les acteurs ne souhaitent pas nous
entendons de notre côté la nécessaire
stabilité dont chacun a aujourd'hui
besoin en matière de formation continue
les dernières années ont également été
marquées par de grandes évolutions et
une véritable impulsion a été donnée à
ce sujet à travers notamment de
l'élaboration du schéma directeur de la
formation continue en 2019 de la mise en
place de formation ayant l'ambition de
toucher l'ensemble des enseignants plan
mathématiques et français formation
valeur de la République du développement
de la GRH de proximité pour recueillir
au mieux les attentes des personnels ou
encore de la mise en oeuvre à compter de
la rentrée 2022 des écoles académiques
de la formation continue ses avancées
sont essentielles pour permettre à la
formation continue d'atteindre ces deux
objectifs permettre aux enseignants de
s'adapter aux besoins de l'institution
mais également de s'épanouir
professionnellement et personnellement
dans une logique d'évolution de carrière
de formation tout au long de la vie de
qualité de vie au travail susceptible de
renforcer l'attractivité de la
profession
nous avons été toutefois alertés sur
plusieurs difficultés qui ne permettent
pas encore à la France de rattraper son
retard par rapport aux autres États de
l'OCDE et doit faire l'objet d'une
attention importante d'une attention
importante les enseignants regrettent
une trop faible valorisation des
démarches de formation peut ou pas du
tout prise en compte dans leur
déroulement de carrière il souligne que
les formations ne répondent pas toujours
aux besoins malgré une multiplicité
d'acteurs et d'offres nous notons
également une difficulté à évaluer
l'efficacité réelle de ces formations
notamment en classe quelques mois après
qu'elles ont été suivies nous avons
entendu et nous relayons plusieurs
pistes d'évolution autour de la
clarification des priorités de la
formation continue autour de
l'amélioration de la reconnaissance des
formations par davantage de
certification ou encore d'une plus
grande évaluation à froid y compris à
minima par des questionnaires
d'auto-évaluation quelques mois après la
tenue de la formation
font état de demande de formation
surtance scolaire refusées faut de
remplacement disponible cette situation
risque de s'accraver de s'aggraver cette
année compte tenu de la conjoncture et
nous souhaiterions des solutions
puissent être envisagées je vous
remercie beaucoup cher collègue et je
vous propose une suspension de séances
nous reprenons nos travaux
dès que possible merci
nous reprenons de travaux chers
collègues et nous allons écouter le
rapporteur spécial Robin Reda
messieurs les rapporteurs pour avis
chers collègues j'ai le plaisir au nom
de la commission des finances de
rapporter le premier budget de la
mission enseignement scolaire pour ce
quinquennat premier aussi au sens propre
du terme puisqu'il s'agit bien du budget
le plus important de l'État avec 60,2
milliards d'euros de crédit en
augmentation de 3,7 milliards d'euros
par rapport au budget 2022 qu'il me soit
permis ici de me réjouir d'abord d'une
rentrée qu'on annonçait difficile mais
qui s'est passé de façon très honorable
sous le pilotage du ministre dans un
contexte sanitaire bien meilleur que
celui des années précédentes et dans ce
que l'on pourrait appeler un retour à la
normale
je veux rappeler ici que les enjeux liés
à l'école figurent parmi les grandes
priorités du quinquennat du président de
la République ce dernier l'a d'ailleurs
affirmé dès la rentrée scolaire devant
nos recettes d'académie nous rêvons
d'une école qui fasse réussir tous nos
enfants et qui parlent même face réussir
la France ce budget en haut c'est la
traduction de l'hommage unanime que nous
rendons à nos enseignants et de notre
souhait collectif que leur métier soit
revalorisé cette revalorisation doit
prendre une forme sonnante et
trébuchante avec ce budget nous
engageons la revalorisation à la hauteur
de 10% en moyenne des enseignants nous
renforçons aussi les moyens de soutien à
la politique de l'éducation nationale
pour des professeurs mieux formés mieux
accompagnés et dont l'autorité doit être
replacée au cœur des préoccupations pour
faire respecter nos valeurs et nos
principes républicains à cette étape de
mon propos permettez-moi d'avoir une
pensée pour Samuel Paty et en évoquant
sa mémoire pour tous ses collègues
professeurs et professionnels du monde
éducatif qui offre chaque jour pour
garder l'école à l'abri des pressions
religieuses et pour défendre cette belle
protection universelle et humaniste
qu'elle a la laïcité
dans la trajectoire des années
antérieures qui ont vu l'augmentation
des moyens dédiés à l'enseignement
scolaire le budget de la mission 2023
est marqué par plusieurs objectifs
notables d'abord un effort soutenu pour
offrir aux élèves le meilleur
accompagnement possible j'en veux pour
preuve un taux d'encadrement qui
progresse alors même que nous vivons une
forte baisse démographique dans les
classes du premier et du second degré
concrètement cela veut dire que le
nombre de postes d'enseignants restera
plus élevé par rapport aux besoins
permettant une organisation plus souple
et plus qualitative des établissements
scolaires nous pourrions citer par
exemple à poursuivre des démarches de
dédoublement de classe du renforcement
de l'apprentissage des savoirs
fondamentaux ou de nouveaux temps dédiés
à une meilleure orientation des élèves
ensuite un choc d'attractivité pour le
métier d'enseignant qui doit retrouver
dignité et prestige au-delà des
revalorisations générales liées à
l'augmentation du point d'indice à la
pérennisation des mesures du Grenelle de
l'éducation je note l'enveloppe
supplémentaire de 935 millions d'euros
pour tous les enseignants dont une part
correspond au pacte qui sera mis en
discussion avec les enseignants et leurs
représentants la reconnaissance sociale
de l'engagement et des efforts des
enseignants en dehors du temps scolaire
pour être utile aux élèves doit bien se
transformer en salaire supplémentaire
le président de la République a souhaité
par ailleurs libérer l'école de ses
carcans par la préfiguration de ce qui
pourrait être l'école du futur aux côtés
des dispositifs pédagogiques existants
et financés par la mission de
l'enseignement scolaire je veux
mentionner la mise en place du fond
d'innovation pédagogique destinée à
faciliter la mise en oeuvre de projets
éducatifs alors bien sûr il faudra
évaluer ces nouvelles méthodes
pédagogiques notamment en s'appuyant sur
les travaux du Conseil d'évaluation de
l'école qui ont vocation à monter en
puissance et accompagner les équipes
éducatives dans cette vision nouvelle de
l'école permettez-moi d'ailleurs de
souhaiter le succès de cette démarche
financée comme ça a été rappelé
précédemment par la Mission investir
pour la France de 2030
l'école inclusive poursuit par ailleurs
sa montée en puissance avec le
recrutement de 4000 aesh supplémentaires
le budget pour l'accueil des enfants
situation de handicap ou à particularité
est en augmentation de 220 millions
d'euros cette année je rappelle qu'il a
augmenté de 1,3 milliards d'euros depuis
5 ans cela va de pair avec la
reconnaissance du métier des plus de 130
000 aesh qu'il faut encore accompagner
sur la voie d'emploi plus stable et plus
rémunérateur enfin je tiens à mentionner
l'éruption de la question écologique à
l'école dans les contenus d'enseignement
mais aussi dans les projets éducatifs en
lien avec la préservation de la nature
ou encore dans l'attention portait à la
rénovation du bâti scolaire ces
questions sont dévolues aux
collectivités territoriales
particulièrement cette période de
nécessaire sobriété énergétique dans
cette optique et pour terminer
l'enseignement agricole et c'est plus de
200000 élèves proposent des formations
d'excellence dans ce qu'il appelle une
grande aventure du vivant je mentionne
donc aussi les moyens supplémentaires de
67 millions d'euros dont il bénéficie
au-delà d'une formation de qualité
l'enseignement agricole répond aux
enjeux de souveraineté alimentaire en
préparant des opportunités d'emploi qui
ont du sens pour bâtir la culture de
demain et nourrir nos concitoyens en
conclusion je dirais qu'il n'y a pas de
fatalité ni au décrochage éducatifs que
certains exagèrent des fins
politiciennes ni au maintien de
déterminisme encore trop ancré ce budget
qui est un budget d'avenir prend la
mesure d'un véritable combat contre la
montre pour que l'humanisme
l'universalisme le progrès demeure par
l'éducation au fondement de notre
société démocratique je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le député
monsieur le rateur maintenant nous
allons passer aux orateurs des groupes
et pour le groupe Renaissance Graziella
Melchior
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues je
tiens à remercier Monsieur le Rapporteur
spécial Robin Reda et Messieurs les
rapporteurs pour avis Philippe fait et
Christophe Marion pour leur implication
d'un examen du budget de cette mission
si précieuse qui est l'enseignement
scolaire je fais tout d'abord saluer là
aussi inédite 6,4 % pour 2023 du budget
de cette mission qui démontre l'ambition
de notre gouvernement cette augmentation
valorise ce budget à hauteur de 82
milliards 47 et concerne l'ensemble des
6 programmes de la mission ce budget de
sortie de crise sanitaire financera la
scolarisation de plus de 12 millions
d'élèves de la maternelle au lycée de
l'enseignement public et privé pour
l'ensemble des filières générales
technologiques et professionnelle il
faut noter qu'il intervient dans un
contexte de net diminution démographique
pour autant la diminution du schéma
d'emploi d'environ 2100 postes
d'enseignements et sans conséquence sur
le taux d'encadrement des élèves lequel
continue à s'améliorer pour le premier
degré et se stabilise pour le second
degré
la majeure partie de l'augmentation de
ce budget est une réponse au manque
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
que tout le monde a souligné
3,5 milliards d'euros sur les 4,7
milliards d'euros d'augmentation des
crédits de la mission seront alloués à
la revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants
ce budget 2023 est la pierre angulaire
de nombreuses ambitions pour nos écoles
il crée 4000 postes d'Ash pour une école
toujours plus inclusive l'état parachait
également le dédoublement des classes de
grandes sections en Rep il soutiendra le
déploiement des écoles du futur à
travers une enveloppe de 300 millions
d'euros consacré aux Fonds d'innovation
pédagogique d'ici 2025 qu'il portera à
500 millions en 2027
l'école primaire et le socle de la
réussite de tous les élèves le budget
pour l'enseignement scolaire public du
premier degré s'élève à 25,6 milliards
d'euros un chiffre en hausse de 6,4% par
rapport à 2022 ces nouveaux moyens
permettront de poursuivre l'engagement
présidentiel sur la priorité accordée à
l'école primaire depuis 2017 et
notamment l'apprentissage des savoirs
fondamentaux mais pas que cela avec le
même dynamisme mais la même ambition le
budget de l'enseignement scolaire public
du second degré en hausse le 5,3% par
rapport à 2022 ces ressources sont
essentiellement destinées à la réduction
des inégalités qui sont le ferment de
bien des difficultés pour les jeunes un
apprentissage efficace se fait dans un
climat scolaire apaisé où chacun trouve
sa place le budget du programme vie de
l'élève et donc augmenter de 7,5% par
rapport à 2022 par cette augmentation de
budget conséquente aucune place ne sera
laissée au harcèlement et à tout autre
forme de violence scolaire la liberté de
conscience sera favorisée dans nos
écoles ainsi que l'égalité de toutes et
tous les élèves seront aussi éduqués à
la vie citoyenne et à la sexualité c'est
comme ça qu'il grandiront en sérénité la
qualité de vie de nos élèves sera
améliorée à travers le Pass Culture
également et des petits déjeuners
gratuits il faut le rappeler son service
dans des écoles en particulier dans les
territoires les plus fragilisés
l'enseignement privé n'est pas oublié
puisqu'il bénéficie aussi de d'une
augmentation de ses ressources afin
d'améliorer la qualité de la gestion des
ressources humaines dans ces
établissements enfin ce je voudrais vous
poser une une question qui m'interroge
toute
une précision en tout cas sur la hausse
de la rémunération des enseignants en
début de carrière puisqu'elle a été
actée et j'ai été urgent de le faire
cependant la revalorisation à l'entrée
de la carrière entraîne un risque
d'écrasement des grilles de salaire sur
sujet sur lequel j'ai été interrogé par
des enseignants de la circonscription et
j'aimerais savoir si vous si une refonte
en fait de la grille et envisagée et
dans quel délai je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre merci chers
collègues pour le rassemblement national
à Roger judo
le présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre tout le monde ici
connaît les villages que le prince
potenkin fut érigé en 1787 lors du
voyage en Crimée de la Grande Catherine
des façades en bois hâtivement peintes
dissimulées la sombre misère des
villages que traversait l'impératrice de
toutes les Russes et bien monsieur le
ministre l'exercice auquel vous venez de
vous livrer devant nous fait de vous le
Potemkine du macronisme déclinant car le
budget de la mission enseignement
scolaire n'est qu'une accumulation de
faux-semblants qui dissimule mal l'état
alarmant dans lequel se trouve le
système éducatif de notre pays vous
annoncez fièrement une augmentation de
3,7 milliards d'euros mais à quoi est
exactement employé cette somme
1,7 milliards vont à la revalorisation
nous prennent l'indice le glissement
vieillasse technicité nous coûte 770
millions d'euros ces dépenses sont
évidemment aucun rapport avec la
politique éducative proprement dite il
reste donc environ un virgule 9
milliards en année pleine pour augmenter
de 10% le traitement de jeunes
professeur avec une inflation de 7%,
vous avouerez que ça fait peu une
ressemblent pas à une avancée sociale
remarquable notons au passage tout de
même des petites mesquineries vous
supprimez plus de 2000 emplois dont 11
cents de professeurs des écoles merci
pour la priorité aux primaire et
l'augmentation des débutants n’entrera
en vigueur de toute façon qu'en
septembre 2023 mais le mystère plane
encore sur la seconde augmentation
conditionnelle celle-ci qui sera
réservée aux professeurs qui auront
conclu impact mais l'impact avec qui
avec vous-même avec Monsieur Macron
monsieur le ministre des professeurs ne
signent pas de pacte ce sont les agents
de l'État qui recrutaient à l'occasion
de concours difficile vous êtes agrégé
moi aussi aussi nous savons donc de quoi
il s'agit le travail des professeurs est
défini par des textes réglementaires il
n'y a pas de pacte ni de contrat nous ne
sommes pas aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique
voulez-vous donc diviser le corps
enseignant entre ceux qui touchent le
minimum syndical et les super prof qui
auront signé un pacte mais pardon de
l'essentiel parlons des élèves parlons
des résultats de ceci certes vous
poursuivez les dédoublements des classes
de l'éducation prioritaire mais vous
devriez savoir que si la pédagogie ne
change pas le nombre d'élèves par classe
ne produit pas mécaniquement de progrès
et l'éducation prioritaire ne concerne
que 20% des écoliers de France vous
envisagez de réfléchir à l'avenir du
collège pardon dont vous découvrez d'un
peu tard qu'il est depuis plus de 30 ans
Monsieur le Ministre l'enfant malade du
système scolaire le baccalauréat blanc
Caire tourne à la farce et vous ne
voulez pas y toucher
en fait monsieur le ministre ce
en fait monsieur le ministre ce projet
de budget de la mission enseignement
scolaire premier budget de l'État
investissement de nature stratégique
dont les enjeux sont vitaux pour
l'avenir de la nation oui ce budget est
un budget de gestion et non un budget de
mission vous savez pourtant que les mots
dont souffrent notre système éducatif
sont de nature systémique le président
de la République lui-même vous a mis sur
la voie quelque chose ne va pas dans
notre organisation a-t-il dit mais hélas
vous semblez vous interdire à vous-même
toute action décisive visant à améliorer
les apprentissages vous déclarez urbés
par exemple que ce n'est pas un
augmentant les horaires que l'on
améliore les performances scolaires ou
avait donc avez-vous donc acquis cette
certitude savez-vous que les écoliers de
1945 oui ceux du CNR du vrai du
programme Langevin wallon avait 188
journées de cours par an avec leur
semaine comptait 30 heures soit 1128
heures par an aujourd'hui nous sommes à
144 journées 24 heures de cours soit 864
heures par an
entre temps nos enfants passent plus de
1200 heures par an sur des sur les
écrans véritables fabriques du crétin
bon vous devriez peut-être réfléchir à
tout cela tout comme la télévision de la
révision de la vie actuelle des
enseignements au profit quasi exclusif
du français et des mathématiques au
moins jusqu'au CM1 ou à la révision des
ors des professeurs monsieur le ministre
nous auront peut-être l'occasion n'a pas
dans le débattre dans l'hémicycle mais
pour l'heure devant cette commission
nous ne renoncerons pas et défendront de
nombreux amendements disons à restaurer
l'efficacité et la dignité de l'école de
la République je remercie merci monsieur
le député pour elle est finups Jérôme
Legavre et je rappelle que seuls les
orateurs ont la parole merci beaucoup
alors là ça va merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre au
moment où nous examinons les mesures
concernant l'école contenu dans ce
projet de loi de finances projet pour
lequel le gouvernement vient d'actionner
le 49-3 quintessence de la démocratie
comme c'est bien connu vous me
permettrez de commencer par un exemple
voici ce qui écrivent les parents du
lycée Alfred Nobel de Clichy-sous-Bois
depuis le début de l'année un grand
nombre d'élèves des voix
professionnelles se voient privés de
cours de maths et d'anglais l'inquiétude
des parents grandit et le stress des
élèves avec les échéances des examens et
à l'approche des inscriptions sur
parcoursup comment faire pour avoir des
remplaçants et rattraper les centaines
d'heures de cours perdus nous savons que
cette situation est tout sauf
exceptionnelle et qu'elle est désormais
la règle ordinaire selon une enquête du
SNPDEN principale syndicat de chef
d'établissement un mois après la rentrée
35% des établissements ont au moins un
poste d'enseignant vacants 32% ont au
moins une absence longue non remplacée
dans le premier degré dans plusieurs
départements les équipes de remplaçant
sont déjà à sec cette situation
inacceptable et de fait la négation du
droit à l'instruction qui est due à tous
les élèves de ce pays elle est le
résultat direct des politiques
destructrices de l'école conduite depuis
des années et considérablement aggravée
par votre prédécesseur le ministre
Jean-Michel Blanquer l'urgence est donc
de changer de cap nous avons examiné
avec la plus grande attention les
mesures de ce projet de loi de finance
le schéma d'emploi révèle que 2100
emplois d'enseignants sont supprimés
dans ce projet de budget 1117 dans le
premier degré public 481 dans le second
degré public et cela s'ajoute aux 7900
suppressions de poste du quinquennat
précédent il en va de même pour toutes
les catégories de personnelles tant de
vie scolaire que de santé scolaire alors
même que les besoins sont urgents de
très nombreux parlementaires
d'appartenance très différentes ne
cessent d’alerter sur le sort des élèves
en situation de handicap vous annoncez
4000 emplois d'Ash supplémentaires mais
combien de postes sont réellement
pourvus pour les parlementaires il est
impossible de contrôler les lignes
budgétaires qui leur est consacrées et
sur le terrain on manque partout on sait
pourquoi c'est personnels touchent et
vont continuer de toucher un salaire de
misère en moyenne de 800 euros par mois
pour un temps imposé de 24 heures
hebdomadaires monsieur le ministre plus
de 4000 postes d'enseignants n'ont pas
été pourvu cette année à l'issue des
concours de recrutement d'où vient ce
manque inédit d'enseignants de la
dégradation continue des conditions de
travail et d'une rémunération totalement
insuffisante vous annoncez 10% de
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants mais elle inclut
l'augmentation de trois et demi pour
cent de la valeur du point d'indice
augmentation bien en deçà de l'inflation
à partir de septembre 2023 il faudra
donc attendre un an les enseignants
recevront en moyenne 172 euros bruts par
mois en plus comme on est loin des 10%
annoncés ajoutons sur ce point que 300
millions seront attribués aux
enseignants qui accepteraient des tâches
supplémentaires sans rapport avec
l'enseignement c'est-à-dire travailler
plus pour perdre moins pendant ce temps
les cadeaux à l'école privée se
poursuivent cette année encore puisque
l'enseignement privé sous contrat est
une fois de plus privilégié par rapport
à l'enseignement public cette
privatisation si on rampante et
d'ailleurs le contenu réel de la réforme
de la voie professionnelle contre
laquelle les professeurs de lycée
professionnels se sont massivement mis
en grève hier vous décidez aujourd'hui
de réduire drastiquement le temps
d'enseignement en lycée professionnel
alors même que l'enseignement
professionnel a été institué après
guerre pour soustraire la jeunesse à la
tutelle des patrons et que les jeunes en
apprentissage réussissent moins bien que
ce statut scolaire vous décidez de
favoriser toujours plus l'apprentissage
pour fournir une main d'oeuvre gratuite
aux entreprises et remplacer des
salariés par des apprentis sous-payés
vous l'avez compris nous est impossible
d'approuver de voter les mesures
contenues dans ce PLF nous défendrons
des amendements appuyés sur les deux
propositions de loi que nous avons
présenté en cette rentrée visant
notamment organiser des concours
exceptionnels de recrutement créer un
prêt recrutement des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale revaloriser
réellement les salaires de 10% créer un
corps d'aush dans la fonction publique
les entendrez-vous les prendrez-vous en
compte et renoncerez-vous à la réforme
de la voie professionnelle massivement
rejetée par les personnels et leurs
organisations
merci monsieur le député pour les
républicains Alexandre portier merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre quand on aborde l'étude d'un
budget de plus de 59 milliards le risque
forcément c'est de se perdre et de
confondre parfois les moyens et les fins
l'école c'est quoi c'est d'abord une
mission d'intérêt général et un projet
républicain comme vous le savez et c'est
ensuite des moyens humains et matériels
pour les mettre en oeuvre et en matière
d'instructions publiques et
d'enseignement c'est bien je pense qu'on
est d'accord là-dessus la fin qui
justifie les moyens votez des chiffres
c'est toujours aussi approuver un projet
et la question pour nous c'est peut-on
voter ces chiffres et peut-on approuver
le projet j'ai votre simple en trois
points pour reprendre un peu de hauteur
le premier ce sera le budget l'enveloppe
dédiée à l'enseignement scolaire est en
hausse 6,5% pour 2023 avec une
trajectoire avec 1,9 milliards en année
pleine ce budget prévoit une
augmentation des salaires des
enseignants c'est bien et c'est juste il
n'est pas acceptable que dans notre pays
les têtes les mieux faites commencent
leur carrière 1450 après un bac+5 et
c'est pourtant le cas de celui qui vient
d'avoir un CAPES comme vous le savez en
France l'effort et le travail doivent
payer et on doit d'abord l'assumer dans
le cœur même de la méritocratie
républicaine à savoir l'école
problème c'est que la révélation je cite
au départ inconditionnel ne sera pas
tout à fait tenu la promesse n'est pas
tenue et pas maintenant puisque l'on
sait que les augmentations n'entreront
en vigueur comme vous l'avez rappelé
qu'à la rentrée de septembre 2023
malheureusement et nous sommes loin dans
l'immédiat des 2000 euros net annoncés
ma question est simple quand ils seront
nous vraiment monsieur le ministre ma
deuxième question c'est sur les
conditions de travail il nous faut plus
d'enseignants mieux payés mieux former
mais pas que et monsieur le ministre
nous vous avions alerté ici même le
malaise d'enseignant ne tient pas qu'à
des chiffres comme vous le savez mais
aussi à la reconnaissance un problème
pas de vagues et peu croire encore au
soutien de l'institution en cas de
difficulté les enseignants au quotidien
se sont isolés dans leur pratique
je vous avais interrogé notamment ici
même sur la question de l'autorité et
mon collègue Maximino sur la médecine du
travail ce budget ne dit rien
concrètement des réponses que vous
voulez y apporter quid des infirmières
et des assistants de service social de
l'éducation nationale dont le malaise
est profondé à moyen constant à des
besoins en augmentation elles sont
nombreuses depuis 2017 à quitté
l'éducation nationale en raison
notamment de la faiblesse des salaires
4000 postes aussi pour les avsh que vous
avez rappelé on les salue évidemment
mais quiddes des pratiques sur le
terrain qui posent question j'avais cité
les pial on pourrait parler de la
généralisation des avsh mutualisés qui
soyons honnêtes masque des réalités de
terrain parfois moins réjouissante les
chiffres annoncés font un peu écran pour
masquer les qualités de prise en charge
beaucoup plus
aléatoire en réalité et puis enfin le
projet ce qui est vraiment l'essentiel
de
l'éducation nationale pour nous et j'en
suis désolé mais honnêtement il est un
peu illisible aujourd'hui inclusion
égalité fille garçon harcèlement
scolaire sport valeurs de la République
lutte contre le fondamentalisme l'école
fait un peu de tout c'est l'impression
qu'elle donne mais le fait-elle bien
c'est moins sûr et surtout et ses
enseignants professeurs des écoles
directeur de porter tous ces sujets
c'est encore moins sûr vous connaissez
l'adage qui trop embrasse mal étreint et
beaucoup de questions restent en suspens
pendant ce temps ou en sommes-nous sur
la transmission des serveurs
fondamentaux pour rien n'est fait pour
remédier en profondeur à l'effondrement
de la maîtrise de notre propre langue ou
en sommes-nous sur le niveau en
mathématiques où l'on assiste ces
dernières années aux armes
incompréhensibles sur leur suppression
plus leur retour en terminale ou en
sommes-nous sur l'autonomie des
établissements et notamment les
résultats de l'expérimentation à
Marseille sur lesquels les retours sont
bien discrets aujourd'hui tous les
problèmes ne se résolvent pas par les
moyens il faut d'abord un projet une
stratégie incapable et loin de là ce
budget peine vraiment à nous en
convaincre nous cherchons la cohérence
de votre projet et ce n'est pas j'en
suis désolé le fond d'innovation
pédagogique énième saupoudrage qui
changera cela merci
merci monsieur le député pour les
démocrates Géraldine Bannier
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le ministre pour ce
premier budget de la législature
consacrée à l'enseignement scolaire nous
pouvons nous féliciter que les moyens
promis de la campagne présidentielle et
la campagne législative soit au
rendez-vous car c'est inédit et il faut
le souligner à la rentrée 2023 les
professeurs néotitaires seront rémunérés
au-dessus de 2000 euros net par mois
avec cette avancée la France continue
son long chemin pour renforcer
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
mais elle corrige surtout un retard
incompréhensible qui fait que les jeunes
professeurs français sont bien moins
payés que leurs homologues dans les pays
de l'OCDE monsieur le ministre s'est
avancé est importante elle était
attendue mais elle doit ne pas nous
faire perdre de vue que le regain
d'attractivité de ce beau métier de
professeur sur l'ensemble de la carrière
ne relèvera pas que l'augmentation des
salaires aussi les conditions et le
cadre du travail sont importants et je
crains que les flous qui existent pour
l'instant sur la partie conditionnelle
des revalorisations demeure une source
d'inquiétude pour de nombreux
enseignants vous nous avez tout à
l'heure apporté quelques éclairages en
évoquant le suivi individualisé où le
remplacement de courte durée c'est
peut-être de nature à rassurer les
enseignants parce que ce sont des tâches
qui étaient déjà en partie effectuées
par eux en ce qui concerne les élèves
nous pouvons nous réjouir de voir leur
encadrement et leur condition
s'améliorer grâce à une condition
volontariste que vous avez super durer
une politique pardon cette année encore
le taux d'encadrement continuera de
s'améliorer malgré quelques postes de
professeurs en moins des objectifs comme
les 30 minutes de sport quotidiens ou
les 100% EAC permettront pour leur part
de contribuer pleinement à
l'épanouissement des enfants et leur
faire découvrir des activités nouvelles
le développement de ces activités doit
se faire le plus possible au travers
d'actions communes avec les acteurs de
nos territoires pour le sport la culture
mais aussi au travers de toute activité
pédagogique qui pourra venir enrichir le
parcours des enfants
je veux saluer en ce sens l'initiative
du Fonds d'innovation pédagogique doté
de 150 millions d'euros dès 2023 donc
vous avez précisé tout à l'heure les
contours de son intervention et qui
s'inscrit pleinement dans cette volonté
d'impliquer les acteurs du territoire
si j'évoquais au début de mon
intervention les revalorisation pour les
professeurs il faut également noter
celles pour les personnels non
enseignants qui sont évidemment
primordiales je salue notamment
l'extension de la prime REP et rêve plus
aux AED et aesh extension importante
pour ses professions aux revenus encore
trop faibles vous avez aussi évoqué la
revalorisation attendue pour la filière
médico-sociale c'est un pas important
aussi l'arrivée de 4000 nouveaux postes
d'aesh à la rentrée prochaine avec un
après un recrutement équivalent cette
rentrée 2022 continuera d'agir pour
Nicole plus inclusive je tiens ici
rappeler que d'énormes progrès ont été
faits depuis 2017 mais qui nous reste
beaucoup de travail tant sur la
rémunération que sur l'organisation des
tâches des aesh
à ce propos se pose la question de
l'équilibre de l'encadrement et du
nombre d'élèves par classe afin de mieux
accueillir les élèves qu'ils soient en
situation de handicap ou non dans un
contexte d'inflation des notifications
peut-être pourrez-vous nous indiquer où
on est la réflexion ministérielle à ce
sujet
évidemment le groupe démocrate salut les
crédits de la mission enseignement
scolaire et puis je fais un petit clin
d'oeil de soutien aussi au crédit de la
qui sont apportés à l'enseignement
agricole bien que ça relève pas
forcément de notre mission
je vous remercie madame la députée pour
les socialistes et apparentés Fatiha qui
loue
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
alors l'exode l'examen du projet de loi
de finance 2023 permet de mettre en
lumière les défaillances de la politique
du gouvernement en matière d'éducation
scolaire loin des promesses réitérer
d'une nouvelle école inclusive et d'un
professeur devant chaque classe nous
sommes toujours face à l'école de la
pénurie plus de 2000 postes
d'enseignants sont supprimés par le
gouvernement dans ce projet de loi de
finances
dont sont dont
1117 dans le premier degré et 481 en
collège et lycée nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de telles suppression et
demandant le rétablissement des ETP
supprimer dans le public pour préserver
notre école républicaine alors qu'à
rentrer prochaine et lycées verront
l'arrivée de 10000 élèves
supplémentaires et que 8000 poches ont
été supprimés lors du précédent
quinquennat le gouvernement justifie ses
professeurs en moins par une baisse du
nombre d'élèves pourtant le contenu est
pas par ailleurs le dédoublement des
16000 classes en éducation prioritaire
et a été réalisé sans la création de
postes équivalents comment poursuivre
cette politique en grande section de
maternelle en continuant à supprimer des
enseignants
concernant la revalorisation salariale
des enseignants celles-ci nous concerne
finalement que 40% des professeurs quant
à la revalorisation conditionnelle nous
nous opposons bien sûr à la doctrine du
travailler plus pour gagner plus pour
des enseignants dont le pouvoir d'achat
chaque année est toujours plus bas
notre position est claire nous
contestons ces mesures d'annonce et
demandons de réels mesures financer qui
permettraient une revue une
revalorisation salariale de 10% pour
l'ensemble pour l'ensemble des
enseignants sans critères d'ancienneté
ni mission supplémentaire
s'agissant enfin des autres personnels
de l'Éducation nationale le groupe
socialiste est apparenté se réjouit de
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
des AED d'autant plus que le précédent
s'est traduit par une baisse de 2000 AED
toutefois les projets de décret à venir
concernant les primes
REP et réplus pour les AED et pour les
aesh ne prévoit pas le même les mêmes
montants de prime que pour les autres
personnels je rappelle le montant des
primes prévues pour
2023263 euros en raid plus
1106 euros en reparrant contre
5114 euros et 100
734 euros pour tous les autres
personnels rappelons donc ici que les
AED et le aesh ne sont pas des demi
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
qu'à ce titre nous exigeons un
alignement des primes sur celle des
autres personnels
de la même manière si la création de 100
postes supplémentaire de CPE va dans le
bon sens
elle ne compensent pas la perte des 395
CPE c'est cinq dernières années
par ailleurs la baisse de 30% des
médecins scolaires sous le précédent
quinquennat est une réelle inquiétude
pour les parents comme pour les
personnels
et comme aucun poste supplémentaire
n'est prévu dans le PLF la situation ne
pourra s'améliorer
c'est un véritable plan scolaire plan
pardon médecine scolaire que nous
réclamons comprenant le recrutement
massif de personnels de santé
la création des deux 4000 nouveaux
postes d'aosh témoignent d'un effort du
gouvernement mais leurs conditions de
travail et notamment leur salaire très
précaires ne permettront pas un
remplissage des postes ouverts en
Seine-Saint-Denis ce sont près de 1000
postes d'aesh qui n'étaient pas pourvu à
la rentrée pour résumer le budget 2023
pour l'enseignement scolaire contient
quelques avancées mais surtout beaucoup
de manques que nous traiterons de
corriger par les amendements que nous
porterons je vous remercie madame la
députée pour horizon et apparenter Agnès
Carrel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai été particulièrement
attentive à votre exposé sur le budget
2023 et je ne peux que me réjouir de la
hausse importante du budget de
l'Éducation nationale la première
question concerne la revalorisation
salariale des enseignants je salue cet
effort ce beau métier que j'ai exécé
pendant plusieurs décennies souffrent
depuis plusieurs années d'une baisse des
vocation et je le regrette mal considéré
mal rémunéré exercer dans des conditions
trop souvent difficiles il séduit de
moins en moins de jeunes le gouvernement
a décidé de faire un effort important en
faveur des enseignants notamment en
revalorisant leur salaire des
concertations ont été annoncées en ce
début de mois pour fixer les cadres
précis de ces revalorisations salariales
votre effort porte d'abord et surtout
sur les enseignants en début de carrière
puisque comme nouvelle enseignant ne
débutera sa carrière à moins de 2000
euros nets par mois à temps plein les
autres enseignants seront également
concernés par les revalorisations mais
elle serait en partie à vous de nous
préciser dans quelle mesure conditionné
à la réalisation de nouvelles missions
de quoi s'agit-il de nouveaux de
nombreux enseignants prennent déjà part
à des tâches supplémentaires et cumulent
de nombreuses heures avec leur mission
première en dehors des heures de cours
préparation des cours correction
évaluation réunion etc il sera également
possible pour eux d'avoir un avancement
plus rapide de carrière comme l'accès à
la classe exceptionnelle à la leur
classe ce qui pourrait de facto conduire
à une hausse accélérée de leur
rémunération mais qu'en est-il
réellement les enseignants enfin de
carrière sont-ils concernés par ces
mesures ils ne peuvent être perdants par
rapport à un enseignant qui débute
qu'est-ce qui peut les motiver pour
assumer leurs dernières années eux qui
sont une réelle plus-value ce personnel
expérimenté est une vraie richesse ils
font aussi des missions supplémentaires
comme le tutorat qui rapportait au taux
horaire et peu attrayant pouvez-vous
nous faire un premier retour des
négociations et des avancées notamment
pour les enseignants en fin de carrière
la seconde partie de mon intervention
porte sur l'une des deux priorités
fixées par le Président de la République
l'éducation artistique et culturel EAC
je réaffirme que l'accès à la culture
est un vecteur d'intégration une
véritable ouverture et évidemment un
facilitateur des apprentissages votre
ministère est celui de la culture ont
développé ensemble un plan d'action
intitulé à l'école des arts et de la
culture afin de permettre à tous les
élèves de bénéficier d'un parcours
artistique et culturel de qualité cet
objectif 100% EAC est passé par la
généralisation en 2022 des actions
artistiques et culturelles chaque année
pour tous les élèves en complémentarité
avec les enseignements artistiques tous
les élèves sont concernés d'autres
mesures ont été prises et rencontrent un
franc succès comme le plan chorale j'y
tiens énormément le dispositif quart
d'heure des lectures le Pass Culture
scolaire étant du prochainement au
sixième cinquième pour des actions
communes cette enveloppe permet aux
professeurs des classes de sixième à la
terminale de financer des activités
d'éducation artistiques et culturelle
pour la classe entière et Corcelles
concerne l'ensemble de notre territoire
si c'est 25 euros en moyenne par année
et par élève représente un effort
important cela semble néanmoins et hélas
insuffisant l'accent doit être mis plus
encore sur ceux qui sont éloignés des
lieux culturels et je pense en
particulier aux élèves des zones rurales
qui dès qu'il sorte de l'établissement
sont vite rattrapés par des contraintes
budgétaires le coût de chaque sortie est
assujetti à son transport et le projet
est souvent rejeté pour cette raison par
exemple l'organisation des voyages
scolaires culturels et linguistiques et
de plus en plus coûteuse pourtant nous
connaissons le bénéfice que représente
ces séjours autrement apprendre or les
murs conjuguer le savoir être et le
savoir-faire fédérer le groupe autour
d'un projet voilà ce qui donne du sens
d'ailleurs nous parlions de tâches
supplémentaires voilà un exemple
d'investissement des enseignants qui
au-delà de toute la géologie mettent en
place bien en amont pour la préparation
de ce voyage donne 100% de leur temps
pendant le séjour mais bien au-delà de
toutes ces conditions considérations
pédagogiques auxquelles vous adhérez
monsieur le ministre j'en suis sûr
mesures supplémentaires qui peuvent être
prises pour ouvrir plus encore la
culture à tous les jeunes qui en sont
les plus éloignés et pas toujours ou du
moins pas seulement par les kilomètres
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour les écologistes nupes Francesca
Pasquini
non mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue pour le groupe
écologiste le budget qui nous est
présenté n'est pas à la hauteur alors
que nous traversons de multiples crises
sociales écologique sanitaire
diplomatique notre école doit plus que
jamais former des citoyens et des
citoyennes éclairés pourtant depuis
quelques années l'école de la République
va s'y sur son socle l'écart de résultat
entre élèves favorisés et défavorisés se
creuse les élèves doutent du sens à
donner à leur apprentissage les
enseignants sont épuisés moralement
surtout dans l'éducation prioritaire et
les établissements peinent à suivre le
rythme frénétique des réformes nous
pouvons le dire sans
exagération notre système éducatif est
au bord du précipice or ce que vous nous
proposez pour sauver l'école d'un péril
certain est une suite de mesures
anecdotique tout d'abord sur la question
des salaires durant l'entre de Tours le
candidat Emmanuel Macron a promis une
hausse je cite d'environ 10% des
salaires des enseignants de manière
inconditionnel cette mesure
électoraliste n'a pas fait long feu
puisque dans le budget seul 635 millions
d'euros sont affectés à une augmentation
inconditionnelle aux primaires cela
ferait une augmentation de 30 euros par
mois il va sans dire que l'on est loin
du choc d'attractivité dans la
profession a tant besoin quant à la part
variable des salaires de 300 millions
est constituent un affront pour les
enseignants une note de l'adepte parue
ce matin même montrent que la moitié des
enseignants déclare travailler au moins
43 heures par semaine comme le Sénat l'a
rappelé les enseignants de France
passent davantage de temps à enseigner
que leurs collègues dans les pays
européens les hausses de salaire ne sont
donc pas une faveur monsieur le ministre
elles sont de droit et il n'est pas
question qu'elle soit conditionnée à
d'autres activités comme celles évoquées
sur la pose méridienne
ensuite sur la question des Fonds
d'innovation annoncé dans la
précipitation dans les écoles de
Marseille il est censé permettre aux
écoles de devenir des laboratoires
innovants si l'idée est bonne son
application laisse à désirer les fonds
proposées s'élèvent à 150 millions
d'euros ce qui ferait pour chaque
établissement un total de 2500 euros
alors même que certaines écoles massent
marseillaises ont reçu des sommes allant
de 10000 à 20000 euros comme dans la
recherche le gouvernement s'apprête à
créer de la compétition entre les
établissements pour obtenir les fonds et
à instaurer un climat de défiance dans
l'éducation nationale nous souhaitons
donc le réaffirmer ici avec force
l'école n'est pas un marché et les
établissements ne sont pas des startups
innovantes l'idéologie libérale n'a
aucune place dans l'école de la
République de manière générale ce budget
s'inscrit dans la lignée des précédents
avec des mesures élitiste comme elle le
renforcement des internats d'excellence
la conditionnalité des salaires la
création de classe européenne
supplémentaires la entre établissement
et surtout la réforme à venir du lycée
professionnel notre vision de l'école
républicaine est tout autre nous
écologistes sommes pour une école
ouverte qui n'enferme pas les élèves
dans des filières cloisonnées mais qui
accompagnent toutes les ambitions vers
tous les horizons une école émancipée
qui forme des consciences libres et
éclairées et non uniquement des
travailleurs une école du bien commun
qui prépare les élèves à être des
citoyens engagés dans le en leur
transmettant le respect de la valeur
humaine et du vivant une école
bienveillante pour les personnels qui
reconnaît les enseignants les Atsems les
AED les aesh les psychologues les
infirmières les médecins alors juste
valeur loin de la maltraitance
institutionnelle actuelle nous aurons
l'occasion de détailler tout au long de
la discussion notre vision de l'école et
les moyens concrets que nous proposons
pour y parvenir il n'est pas trop tard
pour changer de cap monsieur le ministre
et donner enfin un sens concret aux
valeurs républicaines d'égalité et de
fraternité
merci madame la députée pour le groupe
GDR nups Soumia bouroar
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues nous faisons
toutes et tous le même constat le milieu
scolaire étant souffrance cela fait
maintenant plusieurs années que les
enseignants les personnels
administratifs les aesh alerte le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale sur
le manque de reconnaissance de leur
profession et leur rémunération en vain
cette rentrée scolaire a été marquée par
une crise importante du recrutement ne
permettant pas de mettre un professeur
devant chaque classe pourtant ce budget
acte la suppression de 2000 enseignants
alors qu'il manque des professeurs dans
toutes les académies contrairement à la
vision que vous défendez la baisse de la
démographie devrait être l'occasion
d'accompagner les élèves avec des
effectifs réduits pour répondre plus
précisément à leurs difficultés
ce budget présente un paradoxe curieux
d'un côté la revalorisation des salaires
des enseignants à 2000 euros net en
début de carrière pour tenter de
renforcer l'attractivité du métier de
l'autre la suppression de 2000 postes
l'instruction de nos enfants futurs
citoyennes et citoyens ne peut se
satisfaire de ce en même temps la
question de la revalorisation des
milieux des milieux de carrière dans la
prophétorah se pose alors que rien n'a
été annoncé nous espérons que le travail
engagé avec les syndicats débouchera sur
une augmentation de l'ensemble des
grilles de traitement pour ne pas
pénaliser celles et ceux qui ont le plus
souple souffert du gel du point d'indice
parallèlement la situation de la
médecine scolaire est très inquiétante
alors que la crise sanitaire liée à la
covid-19 et les confinements ont
profondément marqué certains enfants les
chiffres démontrent la baisse massive
des médecins psychologues et personnels
infirmiers scolaire sur l'année scolaire
21 22 seulement
843 médecins exercaient sur tout le
territoire français le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale ne semble pas
prendre la mesure du rôle primordial des
personnels médicaux dans les écoles les
primes ne pourront pas répondre à cette
crise structurelle et dans quelques
années malheureusement je le pense il
n'y aura plus de médecins scolaire si on
le faisait si nous ne faisons rien
par ailleurs l'accueil et l'instruction
des élèves en situation de handicap à
l'école était présenté comme l'une des
priorités de votre prédécesseur force
est de constater que le compte n'y est
pas le manque d'Osh et le symptôme d'une
profession précaire des considérée
rémunéré en dessous de seuil de propreté
et frappé par un fort pourcentage de
démission et cela touche principalement
les femmes ce sont des enfants qui sont
sans prise en charge et leur parents qui
payent cette situation vous le faites
ouvrir des postes comme vous le faites
dans ce budget c'est bien mais c'est pas
suffisant sans formation sans plantes
titularisation sans valorisation
salariale ça perd tout son effet enfin
je souhaite vous faire part de mon
opposition face à la réforme des lycées
professionnels qui vient
quelle société voulons-nous nous voulons
des ouvriers et techniciens qualifiés
correctement formés qui donne accès à
des métiers qui sont valorisés dans la
société ne donnez pas l'enseignement aux
entreprises le sacrifice des
enseignements généraux ne permet pas de
répondre au rôle de l'Éducation
nationale de former aussi des citoyennes
et citoyens des citoyens travailleurs
notre projet est celui d'un enseignement
professionnel qui forme au métier du
futur faire des ouvriers des techniciens
les acteurs centraux des mutations à
venir sociaux écologiques ce qui leur
donnera toute leur place dans la société
les jeunes de son pays n'ont pas comme
rôle de pallier le manque de main
d'oeuvre dans les métiers en tension et
sans valorisation
je m'inquiète ensuite parce que cette
réforme
ignore de nombreuses difficultés qui
éprouvent les futurs cheliers à trouver
ne serait-ce qu'un stage comme il existe
encore des discriminations à l'embauche
les discriminations au stage et à
l'alternance sont nombreuses monsieur le
ministre c'est l'état c'est à l'État et
non secteur privé d'assumer
l'instruction des élèves il est encore
temps de changer votre feuille de route
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour le groupe liotte Béatrice Descamps
monsieur le ministre monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues les crédits
de la mission enseignement scolaire sont
en russe il faut s'en réjouir tant les
défis auxquels font face nos écoles sont
nombreuses
la rentrée scolaire 2022 a été
emblématique des difficultés qui se sont
multipliées ces dernières années et en
premier lieu à celle relative au
recrutement d'enseignants
plus d'un mois après la rentrée 35% des
établissements affirment avoir encore au
moins un poste d'enseignant vacants
cette situation inquiète d'autant plus
que les remplaçants ont déjà été
mobilisés pour tenir l'objectif d'avoir
un professeur devant chaque élève à la
rentrée
à ce sujet notre groupe alerte sur la
volonté du gouvernement semble-t-il de
recourir à des dispositifs de type
courant ligne ou au travail en autonomie
sous la surveillance d'un assistant
d'éducation ce n'est semble-t-il pour
nous pas une réponse adaptée ni
suffisante
surtout le budget prévoit la suppression
de 1985 postes d'enseignants la
diminution des effectifs d'élèves ne
doit pas servir de justification à ces
suppressions d'autant que ces dernières
pourraient s'accompagner de suppression
de classe à rebours de la stratégie de
diminuer le nombre d'enfants par classe
pour un meilleur apprentissage
la question du recrutement est
indéniablement liée à celle de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant et
donc des revalorisations salariales qui
sont attendues dans ce budget 935
millions d'euros sont prévus dont 635
seront inconditionnels et 300 liés à
l'acceptation de nouvelles missions
les budgets augmenteront ainsi en
fonction du volontariat notre groupe
craint que le choc d'activité attendue
soit insuffisante nous sommes loin des 6
milliards d'euros de hausse par an
promis par le président lors de la
campagne de la même manière nous nous
interrogeons sur la stratégie
consistant à cibler les débuts de
carrière même si cela est nécessaire
nous appelons à ne pas délaisser les
milieux et fin de carrière
ces discussions étant renvoyées à des
concertations en cours nous ne pouvons
pas à l'heure actuelle appréhender la
réalité concrète de ces revalorisations
futures mais cette méthode interroge les
revalorisations salariales doivent être
inconditionnels et pour l'ensemble des
enseignants pour rappel malgré la hausse
du point d'indice les salaires de nos
professeurs sont encore inférieurs par
rapport à la moyenne de l'OCDE
enfin je veux dire un mot sur la
politique en faveur d'une école
inclusive et en particulier des
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap garant de cet inclusion réussie
des mesures ont été prises pour limiter
la précarité du métier c'est indéniable
mais n'en restons pas là et continuons
d'entendre leur détresse légitime malgré
la hausse continue de passer chaque
rentrée les effectifs restent
insuffisants pour répondre à toutes les
notifications les contrats souvent de
temps partiel imposées sont trop
précaires et les ruminer les
rémunérations loin d'être acceptables
les aesh sont cette année intégrés au
sein du titre 2 mais quelle trajectoire
poursuivez-vous concrètement pour
améliorer les conditions de travail et
de formation de ces aesh n'oublions pas
que ces dysfonctionnements se sont aussi
bien se font aussi bien au détriment de
ces personnels indispensables que des
élèves qui sont les premiers
plaisir de cette situation confrontée un
tourneur important parfois en raison de
nombreuses d'émissions aussi notre
groupe proposera des amendements ce sens
ainsi qu'en direction de la médecine
scolaire et des infirmiers et
infirmières scolaires j'y reviendrai
plus en détail donc tout à l'heure je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous pour
les réponses à cette première série de
questions et soit vous répondez au cas
par cas soit vous vous faites un groupe
et c'est comme vous le souhaitez merci
madame la Présidente merci mesdames et
Messieurs les orateurs des groupes si
vous si cela vous convient je propose de
grouper un certain nombre de vos
interventions qui se recoupent de
manière à ne pas avoir à me répéter et
je vais commencer par le point important
qui est celui que vous avez à peu près
tous souligner qui est celui des de la
hausse de rémunération
les 635 millions qui sont prévus pour
2023 concerne les quatre derniers de
l'année en année pleine il s'agit d'une
hausse qui avoisine les deux milliards
d'euros comme je l'ai dit dans ma
présentation
il ne s'agit pas non plus d'une hausse
qui concernera les débuts de carrière ou
plus exactement il s'agit plutôt de
préciser ce dont on entend par début de
carrière en effet une hausse des débuts
de carrière aurait pour effet de
justement de perpétuer le faux plat qui
existe actuellement ça n'est pas notre
objectif notre objectif c'est comme je
l'ai indiqué de casser le faux plat qui
existe et donc les hausses de
rémunération vont concerner
les 20 premières années de carrière
peut-être très légèrement au dessus des
20 premières années de carrière donc on
est bien au-delà des débuts de carrière
2000 euros net en début de carrière et
plus bien entendu au fur et à mesure que
la carrière s'avance de manière très
provisoire nous avons calculé que pour 5
à 6 ans d'ancienneté on aurait plutôt
une hausse de rémunération qui
tournerait autour de 13 à 14%
d'augmentation donc j'insiste sur les
milieux de carrière qui seront également
revalorisés ensuite se pose la question
de la fin de carrière
les et nous proposons un passage
facilité en hors-classe et en classe
exceptionnelle pour l'instant le passage
en hors-classe concerne 25% des
enseignants le passage en classe
exceptionnel concerne 7% des enseignants
nous souhaitons augmenter la proportion
d'enseignants qui passent en hors-classe
et en classe exceptionnelle ce qui aura
bien entendu des effets sur leur
rémunération avec le passage en Richelle
et une progression salariale finale qui
aura aussi des effets sur leur retraite
je j'insiste sur ces hausses de salaire
et je me permets encore d'insister sur
le fait qu'il ne s'agit pas de hausse de
salaire pour les enseignants débutants
j'ai entendu aussi il y a quelques jours
que certains enseignants débutants
seraient payés plus rémunéré plus que
des enseignants ayant quelques années
d'expérience ce qui est évidemment hors
de question il est hors de question
qu'un enseignant débutant soit mieux
rémunéré qu'un enseignant qui a
plusieurs années d'expérience et pour ça
que nous travaillons à une grille qui
soit une grille reflétant des
augmentations de rémunération qui
soit conséquente pour
les 20 premières années de carrière
comme je l'ai indiqué ensuite il ne
s'agit pas non plus pour nous de dire
que la hausse d'attractivité du métier
se résout et va se résoudre seulement
par des hausses de rémunération ce
serait naïf que de le penser du reste à
l'échelle européenne nous savons que des
pays où les enseignants sont beaucoup
mieux rémunérés qu'en France pensez à
l'Allemagne par exemple ont aussi des
difficultés de recrutement donc la
question des salaires n'est pas la seule
question même si elle est tout à fait
importante il y a d'autres points en
particulier sur les carrières je
pourrais y revenir si vous le souhaitez
des questions également qui se posent
sur le type le format de travail que les
enseignants ont être seuls devant une
classe où et travailler de manière plus
collective voilà des éléments sur
lesquels nous souhaitons également
avancer
enfin à propos des nouvelles missions
les caractéristiques de ces nouvelles
missions seront précisées par les
échanges que nous avons et aurons avec
les organisations syndicales j'insiste
sur un point c'est que un certain nombre
de ces nouvelles missions sont déjà des
missions que les enseignants remplissent
aujourd'hui autrement dit il ne s'agit
pas d'ajouter de façon purement
quantitative d'émissions à ce que les
enseignants font déjà il s'agit aussi de
rémunérer des missions qui sont déjà
accomplies par
enseignants
je ces nouvelles missions et leurs
contenus feront l'objet de d'échanges
autour de l'accompagnement et de
l'orientation des élèves c'est sans
doute un point faible relatif du
secondaire feront aussi l'objet
d'échanges autour de la question des
remplacements de courte durée et
d'autres missions qui visent à améliorer
le fonctionnement des établissements
cela le contenu de ces de ces nouvelles
missions est ouvert nous n'avons pas
d'idées préconçues à ce sujet mais nous
visons à améliorer concrètement
le fonctionnement des établissements des
collèges
enfin des écoles des collèges et des
lycées
en ce qui concerne les aesh comme vous
le savez les notifications ne sont pas
l'éducation nationale personnelle de
l'éducation nationale mais plutôt les
maisons départementales du handicap et
nous avons beaucoup de notifications
avec des variations selon les
départements y compris des notifications
à la dernière minute au moment de la
rentrée et nous avons en effet des
difficultés de recrutement en dépit des
postes d'Ash que nous avons ouvert à la
rentrée 4000 sont prévus également pour
la rentrée prochaine mais nous avons une
réflexion globale à avoir sur la
création des aesh de ces postes d'aesh
en lien avec les départements en lien
avec les MDPH en particulier qui
reconnaissent les difficultés qu'elles
ont eux-mêmes en raison des demandes que
les familles peuvent faire à propos des
notifications et nous avons aussi une
difficulté plus générale qui est liée à
l'embolie si depuis dire du
système de prise en charge des enfants a
besoin et des élèves a besoin
particulier en effet du côté des
instituts médicaux-éducatifs il manque
beaucoup de place il en manque jusqu'à
le dernier chiffre que j'avais été de un
manque de 19000 places du côté des
IME par conséquent un certain nombre
d'élèves qui ne peuvent pas être en IME
sont versés dans le milieu ordinaire par
exemple dans des classes
ULIS les classes ULIS sont surchargées
et donc des élèves sont glissent
eux-mêmes vers les classes disons
ordinaires
bref on a un une question qui est une
question générale à laquelle on ne peut
pas simplement répondre par de la
création de postes aesh sans réfléchir
un peu plus globalement à la à notre
objectif général et à ce que nous
appelons l'acte 2 de l'école inclusive
on ne peut pas simplement répondre par
des créations de poste je vous suis en
revanche sur la question de des
conditions de travail des ash nous avons
progressé avec la CDI
des aesh
environ 20% des aesh sont désormais CDI
avec des progressions de carrière
puisqu'on a maintenant à faire des à des
carrières d'un ESH ce qui n'était pas le
cas dans le passé nous devons faire
mieux en matière de formation même une
formation de 60 heures et déjà prévu
pour les aesh nous devons réfléchir
aussi bien entendu à leur temps de
travail mais là nous heurtons en tout
cas nous avons une difficulté qui est
bien connue qui est celle de du temps
scolaire et du temps périscolaire nous
ne pouvons pas directement rémunérer le
temps périscolaire l'arrêt du Conseil
d'État de novembre 2020 et claire à ce
sujet et nous travaillons à une seule
fiche de paix c'est important pour les
aesh une seule fiche de paie qui
rémunérerait
si toutefois cette solution est
définitivement
solidifier d'un point de vue juridique
une seule fiche de paix qui rémunérerait
les ESH à la fois sur le temps scolaire
et sur le temps périscolaire mais comme
nous ne pouvons pas rémunérer les Abass
sur le temps périscolaire ce serait les
collectivités qui euh ensuite
rembourserait si vous voulez le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale pour
le temps correspondant au Péry scolaire
de manière attendre vers 35 heures pour
les ash qui le souhaitent c'est un
travail assez complexe à mener d'un
point de vue administratif et juridique
mais nous sommes tout à fait conscient
du fait que les 24 heures ou moins
parfois de travail des aesh ne
permettent pas des rémunérations qui
suffisent à propos du dédoublement
pardon des abaissages je rappelle vous
l'avez souligné que c'est les abaissages
travaillant en éducation prioritaire
bénéficieront
d'augmentation comme les AED d'ailleurs
à propos du dédoublement le dédoublement
des grandes sections de maternelle sera
achevée à la rentrée 2024 on est à peu
près à 75% de classe dédoublées en
grande section de maternelle et en effet
comme il a été il a été dit le dwblement
pour qu'il soit pleinement efficace
suppose des changements de pédagogie et
donc suppose aussi une formation des
enseignants faute de quoi le
dédoublement même s'il a une efficacité
n'a pas l'efficacité maximale que l'on
recherche nous sommes d'ailleurs très
attentifs aux résultats des évaluations
de sixième qui seront connues dans
quelques temps puisque les sixième pour
cette rentrée sont les premières portes
à avoir bénéficié en éducation
prioritaire du dédoublement
du dédoublement des CP CE1 et puis des
des grandes sections mais ça n'est pas
encore complétée
à propos de santé scolaire la question
n'est pas pardon de vous le dire de
créer des postes de médecins scolaires
parce que nous créons des postes de
médecine scolaire mais ils ne sont pas
pourvus ils ne sont pas pourvus je le
rappelle et donc moi je veux bien créer
des postes de médecine scolaire mais ça
ce serait pour le coup une une fiction
si derrière la création de ces postes
nous n'avons pas de médecins or il
manque à peu près sur l'ensemble du
territoire 30% 30% des postes ne sont
pas pourvus et dans certains
départements c'est beaucoup plus j'ai en
souvenir des départements ruraux comme
les Vosges par exemple où il y a très
peu de médecins scolaires mais des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvus donc on a
un sujet là qui est que la médecine
scolaire comme d'ailleurs la médecine du
travail n'a plus les internes en
médecine et donc il faut réfléchir à
cette question ce n'est pas simplement
une question de création de postes du
côté des infirmiers nous avons
revalorisé le métier a été fortement
revalorisée ces dernières années avec
des augmentations de rémunération en
2021 en 2022 la prochaine revalorisation
va intervenir en fin d'année 2022 avec
un effet rétroactif au premier janvier
2022 pour une revalorisation de de
pour 2022 de 700 euros en moyenne et
j'observe d'ailleurs du côté des
infirmiers que l'on a neuf postes sur 10
qui sont pourvues et donc on est dans
une situation assez différente en ce qui
concerne l'infirmerie scolaire de la
médecine scolaire le fond d'innovation
pédagogique auquel plusieurs d'entre
vous ont fait allusion n'est pas abondé
à hauteur de 150 millions d'euros
150 millions d'euros c'est la mise de
départ si vous me permettez l'expression
il est abondé sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros et il n'y a pas de concurrence
entre établissement il ne s'agit pas
d'organiser la concurrence entre les
écoles et les établissements tous les
projets pédagogiques bien construits
seront financés par le biais de ce fond
d'innovation pédagogique et je me
réjouis je le note au passage que depuis
deux semaines un grand nombre
d'établissements et d'écoles ont
manifesté leur intérêt nous en avons
compté le week-end dernier on était à
plus de en deux semaines à plus de 600
établissements et on va arriver on va
tutoyer les 1000 établissements
à le 22 pour la veille des vacances
d'automne c'est un bon démarrage j'ai
assisté moi-même un certain nombre de
concertations qui sont des concertations
extrêmement intéressantes ou les équipes
pédagogiques mais aussi les parents
d'élèves l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative donne un point de vue et
réfléchit sur ce qui est peut-être fait
dans l'établissement en question pour ce
qui me concerne c'était un collège et
une école en ce qui concerne la culture
et je suis sensible madame la députée à
votre
point sur la culture
d'abord un élément sur le Pass Culture
dont la généralisation va s'opérer pour
la part collective du Pass Culture pour
les collégiens puisque les 6e vont être
concernés en 2023 je rappelle que pour
une classe cela peut représenter jusqu'à
800 euros à peu près environ 800 euros
je remarque aussi que depuis la rentrée
on a une hausse très spectaculaire des
établissements qui ont réservé une
activité dans le cadre d'une passe
culture on a en un mois de rentrer pour
le mois de septembre on a fait mieux que
l'année dernière de janvier à juin c'est
un démarrage très spectaculaire du Pass
Culture en particulier collectif et
évidemment de cela nous nous réjouissons
il y a cette question qui est posée qui
a été posée par l'une d'entre vous et
qui est tout à fait juste et nous y
sommes très sensible c'est la question
du transport scolaire qui pose des
difficultés en zone rurale j'étais
moi-même dans la Marne et on m'a parlé
de cela avant-hier
nous souhaiterions mais cela est à
échangé bien sûr avec le le mystère de
la culture qui est l'opérateur principal
du Pass Culture nous souhaiterions que
autant que possible les frais de
transport puissent être inclus dans le
Pass Culture mais je conçois que cela
n'est pas simple et que nos collègues et
amis du ministère de la Culture puisse
avoir un point de vue différent mais
cette question des transports est
évidemment une question de nature à
bloquer des projets de sortie culturelle
nous en sommes tout à fait
conscient et nous sommes disposés à
avancer de ce côté là les différents
éléments que vous avez évoqués
madame la députée
à propos d'éducation artistique et
culturelle je les partage au combien il
y a de multiples initiatives qui sont
prises j'observe que dans les
concertations qui s'ouvrent de multiples
initiatives concernent également la
culture je les observe évidemment avec
intérêt vous avez mentionné le quart
d'heure lecture qui est un moment
particulièrement intéressant et
d'ailleurs très suivi dans de très
nombreux établissements il y a beaucoup
de choses et je serai heureux d'ailleurs
de revenir plus en détail vers vous sur
les activités culturelles lors d'une
audition prochaine si vous le souhaitez
enfin la question des lycées
professionnels sur laquelle vous êtes
revenus
lycée question des lycées professionnels
qui est placé sous l'égide direct en
tout cas de la ministre délégué il n'est
pas question pour nous de d'écraser
comme je l'ai entendu de manière
pardonnez-moi un peu caricatural avec
avec l'idée d'un du Moloch capitaliste
qui viendrait broyer les jeunes âmes un
historien de l'éducation me rappelait
hier avec finesse que au moment de la
création des lycées professionnels
sous à l'époque de Jean-Pierre
Chevènement et bien la part des stages
étaient extrêmement faible voir
quasiment nulle et ensuite à chaque fois
que les stages ont été augmentés depuis
maintenant bientôt 40 ans et même
protestations sont revenus on livre les
enfants
au libéralisme le plus échevelé ça va
être terrible ils vont être broyés dans
la mine et dans les usines
terrifiantes qui les attendent pour
mieux les exploiter ça a été à chaque
fois la même ancienne et bien on la
retrouve évidemment aujourd'hui lorsque
l'on part lorsque l'on parle
d'augmentation des stages cela ne
ne doit pas se faire au détriment des
savoirs fondamentaux et c'est un
professeur d'histoire qui vous le dit je
ne suis pas disposé à ce que les
enseignements fondamentaux en français
en mathématiques en histoire en
philosophie en langue soit passé à la
trappe ce serait rendre un bien mauvais
service du reste à nos lycéens mais
aussi aux employeurs comme ils ont pu
nous le dire de façon insistante lors
d'un déplacement du président de la
République au sable de l'Aude et donc
les savoirs fondamentaux c'est important
et nous y tenons de façon tout à fait
clair les groupes de travail qui se
mettent en place à partir de vendredi
vont réfléchir sur ces questions mais il
est évident que nous n'allons pas
revenir là-dessus mais que nous partons
aussi d'une réalité qu'il faut bien
admettre c'est que deux ans après
l'obtention du baccalauréat
professionnel la moitié des lycéens
professionnels n'ont pas d'emploi ça
c'est une réalité alors moi je veux bien
qu'on dise que ça n'a pas d'importance
et qu'il faut continuer comme ça mais je
pense plutôt que c'est rendre service à
nos lycéens que de se soucier de leur
avenir professionnel que ce souci de
leur
capacité à rentrer bien armée sur le
marché du travail tout en étant bien
entendu
ferme sur la formation des futurs
citoyens se soucier de l'employabilité
des lycéens professionnels ça n'est pas
rendre un mauvais service au lycée
professionnel bien au contraire c'est
pourquoi cette réforme qui parieur n'est
pas budgété comme je l'ai indiqué dans
le et pour cause dans le PLF que nous
examinons ce soir c'est pour ça que
cette réforme des lycées professionnels
est utile et quelle sera discutée avec
toutes les parties prenantes
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
première partie de réponse et maintenant
je vais donner la parole à mes collègues
pour un une nouvelle salle de question
pour une minute Anne brunira
je retire ma question madame le
Président d'accord merci beaucoup madame
la députée donc Quentin bataillon
merci madame la Présidente je souhaite
associer à ma question mes excellents
collègues accessibles riaques Emmanuel
Pellerin ainsi que nous rapporteurs
Christophe Marion Philippe fait ainsi
que Robin Reda monsieur mini je souhaite
vous interroger au sujet des
accompagnants des élèves en situation de
handicap dit à ESH même si vous nous
avez déjà apporté des éléments sur ce
point très important ici au sein de
cette commission je pense que nous
pouvons tous nous accorder sur le
travail indispensable qui est le leur et
la qualité avec lesquels ils exercent
leur mission je souhaite non la majorité
présidentielle rappelait les évolutions
nettes et historiques de cette rentrée
scolaire à ce sujet déjà la sécurisation
via CDD de trois ans minimum et non d'un
an dès le premier recrutement comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un acte fort pour la
déprécarisation des aesh également citer
les 4000 emplois supplémentaires créés à
cette lors de cette rentrée à cet effet
ainsi que la revalorisation des
rémunérations avec le premier palier de
150 millions d'euros en janvier dernier
ainsi que comme vous venez de l'accès
aux primes REP et réplus à partir de
cette rentrée sur le terrain vous dit
également monsieur le ministre toutes
les rencontres qui ont déjà eu lieu
notamment dans la commune de Villa
qu'aucun sache que m'a demandé la
création d'un nouveau corps d'éducation
nationale beaucoup ont compris que ça va
complexifier l'entrée que ça va sûrement
même exclure certains d'entre eux vient
un concours national cependant vous
l'avez très bien souligné le sujet qui
est important pour eux c'est la
possibilité pour ceux qui le souhaitent
et j'insiste pour ceux qui le souhaitent
c'est pas le cas pour chacun d'entre eux
d'accéder à un temps plein nous
souhaiterions donc savoir le calendrier
des concertations dont vous venez de
nous parler ainsi que l'association qui
sera faite des parlementaires et des
îles locaux merci monsieur le député
Christine Loire
madame les présidente monsieur le
ministre le harcèlement scolaire est un
phénomène sur-représenté dans les écoles
françaises il concerne 5 à 6% des élèves
excusez-moi chers collègues est-ce que
vous pouvez parler un tout petit peu
plus près du micro parce que on ne vous
entend absolument pas merci de
recommencer la question très merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre le harcèlement scolaire est
un phénomène sur-représenté dans les
écoles françaises il concerne cinq ainsi
pour cent des élèves le Sénat a alerté
le gouvernement sur la fiabilité des
enquêtes menées car trop peu nombreuses
et obsolètes alors Monsieur le Ministre
peu importe le chiffre exact aujourd'hui
près d'un enfant sur 10 serait harcelé
chaque année à l'école si l'on compte
environ 12 millions d'enfants scolarisés
cela fait 1 million de victimes que
comptez-vous faire pour stopper enfin ce
phénomène qui rappelons-le fait trop de
morts chaque année je souhaite également
vous interpeller au sujet des
évaluations nationales chaque année pour
les élèves de CP CE1 et 6e concernés au
niveau de lecture mathématique et
français
à l'heure actuelle les évaluations
n'apportent aucune plus-value concrète
aux principaux intéressés à savoir les
élèves rendre public les résultats de
façon non nominative permettrait aux
enseignants parents élèves d'aborder des
difficultés des élèves à des meilleurs
de meilleurs manières merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci madame la députée Paul
Vanier
sur votre méthode dans un contexte qui
voit ces dernières années les grandes
réformes éducatives être adoptées en
contournant le Parlement je pense
notamment à la réforme du lycée du
baccalauréat vous envisagez
manifestement d'adopter celle de la voie
professionnelle de la même façon puisque
notre assemblée est le représentants de
la nation ne seront pas par leur vote
consultés pour fixer les contours de la
réforme que vous souhaitez mettre en
oeuvre mais dans le contexte de la
journée nous quittons un hémicycle après
que la première ministre est invoqué le
49-3 et mis un terme à notre débat sur
la première partie du projet de loi de
finance alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple les échanges que
nous avons aujourd'hui le travail que
l'ensemble des députés membres de la
commission des Affaires éducatives à
fourni pour préparer cette audition
a-t-il un sens je veux dire les
amendements qui seront votés par les
représentants de la nation seront-ils
ensuite introduits dans un texte qui
sera à nouveau validé ou invalidé par
nous les parlementaires représentants du
peuple français je je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
parler de santé de nos enseignants les
agents de la fonction publique d'État
sont soumis à une visite médicale tous
les cinq ans selon l'accord pour la
fonction publique de 1994 dans les faits
bien souvent les enseignants du premier
et du second degré ne voit le médecin du
travail qu'une fois dans leur vie
professionnelle au moment de leur
titularisation alors face au malaise des
enseignants une attention accrue doit
être accordée au bien-être au travail en
début et en fin de carrière en début de
carrière on observe en effet que les
enseignants français démissionnent de
plus en plus et de plus en plus jeune
enfin carrière les problèmes de santé
s'accroisent la fatigue etc alors
monsieur le ministre ne penserait ne
penseriez-vous pas qu'il serait opportun
comme mon collègue Alexandre portier l'a
proposé dans ses amendements que les
enseignants bénéficient d'une visite
médicale effective régulière notamment
en début de carrière tous les trois ans
jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans et en fin de
carrière tous les trois ans dès l'âge de
50 ans je vous remercie merci madame la
députée et je rappelle à mes collègues
que si vous voulez avoir des
conversations avec vos voisins on peut
tout à fait le comprendre mais les
entendre jusqu'ici c'est un peu plus
difficile notamment pour les orateurs
qui prennent la parole et pour le
ministre et moi-même qui avons
finalement du mal à vous écouter donc
maintenant je laisse la parole à
belkirbelhaddad
la présidente monsieur le ministre le
pélèbre 2023 prévoit un budget sans
précédent pour la revoir réalisation des
professeurs et on sait combien c'est
important le crédit de la mission qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui sont alors de
très largement affectés à cet objectif
crucial en ces temps pas si simple pour
l'attractivité des métiers concernant le
bien-être de l'élève qui constitue
l'autre aspect des politiques éducatives
à développer la pratique sportive doit
jouer un rôle déterminant au 30 minutes
d'activités sportives des armées
généralisées tous les établissements du
premier degré doivent s'ajouter les deux
heures hebdomadaires prévues au collège
un financement semble indispensable pour
dépasser le stade expérimental dans
lequel on se trouve cette mesure
actuellement elle aurait des jeux 2024
pour contribuer à faire de notre pays
nation sportive le moment semble en
effet opportun je ne vois pas forcément
de financement précisément dédié à cette
ambition est-il prévu de la financer via
le programme de 114 ou tout autre
programme en
et dans ce cas comment se fait
l'arbitrage entre les différents projets
merci pour votre éclairage merci
monsieur le député Alexandre Loubet
si madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale à
plusieurs reprises vous avez défendu le
whis vous avez même parlé quatre même
affirmés qu'être wok c'est être
conscientisé vigilant et engagé pour
reprendre vos termes
alors non monsieur le ministre le
walking c'est la démagogie le secteur
isme la soumission la tyrannie des
minorités contre la République la
destruction de la culture française et
des humanités qui ont fondé notre grande
nation l'école ne doit pas se soumettre
à une idéologie étrangère mais enseignée
et transmettre la richesse de notre
culture les donne l'école ne doit pas
cultiver la différence mais l'unité de
la République l'école ne doit pas salir
ni de déconstruire l'histoire de France
mais la connaître et célébrée leur est
national l'école ne doit pas être
conscientisée mais former les jeunes
Français à devenir de futurs citoyens
libres et responsables Charles Péguy
écrivait que le triomphe des démagogies
passagers mais les ruines sont
éternelles le wo keysme qui s'est mis
dans nos écoles menace entre pays alors
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous ce
soir devant nous s'il vous plaît
condamner cette idéologie que le
vaucisme pour que les choses puissent
être claires merci merci monsieur le
député je rappelle que nous sommes dans
une audition budgétaire et que les
questions doivent porter essentiellement
sur le budget je vous remercie chers
collègues puisque nous sommes amenés à
être ensemble de nombre deux heures au
vu aussi des amendements donc si chacun
y met du sien je pense que nous
arriverons jusqu'au bout sans aucun
problème et celles forest
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le mini je voudrais d'avoir vous
remercier pour vos propos sur la réforme
de l'enseignement professionnel à venir
et en particulier votre attachement aux
enseignements généraux dont il ne
faudrait pas en effet que il soit minoré
au profit de l'augmentation des stages
donc vos propos ont été extrêmement
rassurants je vous en remercie ma
question porte justement sur la réforme
de l'enseignement professionnel et sur
un point particulier qui est celui des
campus des métiers et des qualifications
qui permettent de réunir les grands
acteurs de la formation de la recherche
de l'éducation au sens large ainsi que
l'ensemble des partenaires économiques
au regard donc de cette réforme d'une
part et des enjeux de
réindustrialisation qui sont ceux de
notre nation d'autre part c'est qu'en
plus peuvent être des outils majeurs qui
doivent nous permettre notamment de
définir les filières d'avenir qui
répondront au projet de la France plus
une centaine de pôles ont été
labellisées mais pour devenir de
véritables leviers de transformation
c'est qu'en plus doivent monter en
puissance de manière ferme et j'aimerais
savoir monsieur le ministre quelle
évolution vous comptez leur donner et
quelles mesures budgétaire
éventuellement pour l'an prochain je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
Claudia Rouault
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre nous le savons tous certains
enfants ne sautent plus ne cours plus ne
tombent plus cette ce projet de mettre
30 minutes de sport tous les jours au
primaire aujourd'hui
reste dans le flou le plus complet
quels moyens allez-vous donner donc
aux écoles pour pouvoir pratiquer cette
les 30 minutes
allez vous soutenir durablement Lucette
qui se retrouve en situation délicate et
parallèlement au collège quelles mesures
financières comptez vous mettre pour
développer les deux heures
supplémentaires merci merci madame la
députée Bertrand sort
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je tenais tout d'abord à
souligner les forts budgétaires fait par
le gouvernement pour ce budget
d'éducation nationale au titre de 2023
avec une augmentation de 6,4% des
crédits pour un budget de plus de 60
milliards d'euros pour l'année prochaine
cet outil c'est aussi historique pardon
prononce et accentue la politique que
nous avons mise en œuvre depuis 2017
conformément aux engagements du chef de
l'État pour se faire et comme vous
l'avez souligné il fallait un choc
d'attractivité indispensable c'est pour
cela qu'une grande majorité des crédits
affectés à ce budgets permettront de
revaloriser et d'augmenter les salaires
des enseignants je salue cette décision
nécessaire
j'aimerais vous questionner monsieur le
ministre sur les premiers effets
bénéfiques constatés du dédoublement des
classes de CP de CE1 désormais achevées
dédoublements initiés depuis 2017 et
soutenu fortement budgétairement chaque
année comme dans ce budget 2023 quels
effets donc sur l'acquisition des
savoirs des savoir-faire des savoir-être
et des savoirs vivre ensemble c'est
savoir fondamentaux tous nécessaires à
la réussite scolaire de tous les enfants
de la République merci monsieur le
député Léo Walter
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre accompagner les élèves au
portail échanger avec les parents ont
rangé la classe corriger les cahiers
assurer les APC mettre en place les
ateliers installés le parcours sportif
modifier l'affichage échanger avec les
collègues enseignants à ESH animateur
intervenants avec l'équipe municipale
participer à un conseil des maîtres à
une équipe éducative à une équipe de
suivi de scolarisation à une liaison
cm2/6 accueillir un nouvel élève et ses
parents réserver un car un gymnase une
visite renseigner un dossier de classe
transplanté remplir les bulletins
remonter les résultats des évaluations
nationales préparez voir réparer les
ordinateurs ou le vidéoprojecteur ou le
TBI ou la photocopieuse ou la box
internet remplir un javasco une IP ou du
hair ou le PPMS etc voilà quelques-unes
des tâches auxquelles je consacrer la
majeure partie de ma pause méridienne il
y a six mois encore la liste n'est pas
exhaustive je ne dispose que d'une
minute le 16 octobre vous avez pourtant
évoqué comme une piste sérieuse de votre
nouveau pacte enseignant une nouvelle
mission la surveillance de la cour de
récréation entre midi et deux cela
souligne au mieux entre mes
connaissances du métier ma question est
donc la suivante maintenez vous cette
proposition ou comptez-vous enfin
budgétaire la nécessaire revalorisation
sans contrepartie de tous les
enseignants je vous remercie de votre
écoute et de vos réponses merci monsieur
le député monsieur le ministre je vous
laisserai répondre déjà à cette salle de
question puis nous prendrons une mes
collègues dans un deuxième temps alors
je vais commencer par le la question du
harcèlement scolaire qui est en effet
une question très importante
le cette rentrée voit la généralisation
du programme phare à toutes les écoles
primaires élémentaires et à au collège
avec des référents avec le les numéros
verts 30 18 et 30 20 pour le harcèlement
ou le cyber-harcèlement avec une
campagne d'affichage que nous avons
conçu avec la ministre madame cobel qui
seront placés dans les établissements
dans tous les établissements bref il y a
une prise de conscience et une
généralisation
de ce programme visant à faire
finalement passer la peur
du
harcelé au harceleur pour le dire comme
ça nous sommes très vigilants sur cette
question nous avons également formé des
personnels nous avons des référents
académiques en la matière bref la la
cette année scolaire voit la la le
programme PHARE passé la vitesse
supérieure et évidemment je m'en réjouis
parce que ces formes de harcèlement
qu'elles soient violentes ou plus perlée
sont absolument intolérables dans nos
écoles et nos établissements
sur les évaluations nationales je suis
persuadé que les évaluations nationales
sont utiles elles sont pratiquées dans
de très nombreux pays du reste elles
permettent de savoir où on en est
naturellement il faut pouvoir les lire
pouvoir les interpréter de manière
idoine il y a aussi des aspects
qualitatifs que les évaluations ne
mesure pas toujours finement donc les
évaluations nationales ne disent pas
tout du niveau et des résultats
scolaires mais elles sont utiles et
c'est pourquoi en 2023 sous une forme
expérimentale nous les introduisons pour
les classes de quatrième et de CM1 du
reste à propos des effets bénéfiques du
dédoublement des classes c'est une
question que je relis dans le même
mouvement comme je l'indiquais maison
les résultats des évaluations de 6e qui
seront
intéressants de ce point de vue là
la question de la pédagogie est une
question importante et puis également on
s'aperçoit avec le dédoublement que les
écarts entre établissements prêts plus
et établissement or éducation
prioritaire se réduisent on a trois à
cinq points de réduction des écarts
entre ces établissements nous allons
voir ce que cela va donner bien entendu
pour les 6e et donc pour mesurer
l'efficacité dans le temps de
cddoublement l'efficacité forte et
mesurée pour le CP et le CE1 on va voir
ce que ça donne pour les 6e en ce qui
concerne l'utilisation du 49-3
de 49,3 a été utilisé pour la première
partie du budget il ne préjuge en rien
de la seconde partie et c'est pourquoi
je suis là devant vous et que j'ai
l'honneur d'échanger avec vous sur le
budget du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et je le fais évidemment le du
mieux possible cela ne préjuge en rien
de ce qui va être fait je ne je ne peux
pas vous en dire plus à ce stade
sur les la pratique sportive en effet
nous généralisons à l'ensemble des
établissements du primaire la de des
écoles élémentaires
la demi-heure
d'activité physique quotidienne nous
avons d'ailleurs des remontées passées
les premiers temps ou les premiers jours
ou semaines d'organisation
des remontées tout à fait positives à ce
stade et nous sommes dans une phase
expérimentale pour les deux heures de
sport hebdomadaire dans les collèges
actuellement nous avons un groupe
d'environ 200 collèges ou ces deux
heures hebdomadaires sont mises en œuvre
et nous allons faire un bilan régulier
au fur et à mesure de l'année pour voir
où on en est avant son extension dans le
futur on est encore dans une phase
expérimentale à ce sujet je suis
évidemment sensible au point que vous
indiquiez madame la députée à propos des
visites médicales en effet et à propos
de la
de ces visites médicales on a évidemment
une question et je vous avais raison sur
le fait que les visites médicales ne
sont pas suffisantes pour les
enseignants et donc nous faisons les
choses au niveau académique en
encourageant les académies à
conventionné avec des services de santé
et de prévoyance mutualisée dans les
académies concernés pour améliorer la
prise en charge et donc une prise en
charge qui se fait dans des centres de
santé mutualisés
alors on met on met cela en place je
serai tout disposé à ce que l'on aille
un peu plus loin pour l'instant oui ça
n'est que au stade de l'incitation
à contractualiser avec des centres de
santé mutualistes
sur le pardon j'ai oublié une question
qui qui est la question initiale à
propos des aesh et du calendrier on est
en
travail avec la direction des affaires
des affaires juridiques et puis
également avec une nouvelle instance que
nous avons créé au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale qui rassemble les
représentants des collectivités et je me
réjouis d'ailleurs que cet instant se
réunissent sur un ensemble de sujets
d'intérêts communs y compris bien sûr
celui des ash donc nous allons échanger
dans le cadre de cet instant comme sur
d'autres sujets d'ailleurs par exemple
celui du bâti scolaire
sur non il y a eu un malentendu sur je
crois qu'une question était posée il
s'agit pas de demander aux enseignants
de surveiller dans les cours de
récréation c'est pas du tout c'est pas
du tout ce que je voulais dire il y a
une mauvaise expression de ma part ça
n'est pas à cela que je pense à propos
des nouvelles missions dont je parlais
dans le cadre du Pacte des enseignants
je vous rassure et puis je terminerai
par un point sur le campus des campus
des métiers et des qualifications je
crois que c'est vous parlons madame la
député qui me posait qui me posait cette
question en effet il en existe
actuellement sans cesse dont 50 campus
d'excellence c'est à l'évidence
un dispositif qui fonctionne bien parce
que l'offre de formation se trouve être
particulièrement bien adapté aux
réalités économiques et
territorial et donc
nous nous sommes évidemment en soutien
du développement de ces campus des
métiers et des qualifications quant à
Charles Péguy monsieur le député j'ai il
y a quelques années fait un cours sur
Charles Péguy donc je serai ravi de
m'entretenir sur la poésie de Charles
Péguy que j'apprécie particulièrement
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses et pour ces références
littéraires je laisse la parole à Cécile
relac merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre pour ma part je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur le
sujet des décrochage scolaires monsieur
le ministre vous savez parfaitement trop
d'élèves quitte notre système éducatif
sans avoir obtenu de diplôme ou de
niveau de qualification suffisant depuis
une dizaine d'années le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale a lancé une
véritable politique de lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire avec des mesures
importantes voter lors du quinquennat
précédent par les parlementaires tels
que le droit au retour en formation pour
tous les jeunes sortis du système
éducatifs sans diplôme ou encore
l'obligation de formation pour les
jeunes âgés de 18 à de 16 à 18 ans le
taux d'élèves décrocheurs a ainsi
largement baissé mais la crise covid
semble avoir stoppé cette baisse
régulière et nous devons donc agir
or la plupart de nos dispositifs ne
s'adressent qu'aux jeunes de plus de 16
ans Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous préciser les dispositions
budgétaires prévues pour continuer à
lutter contre le décrochage scolaire et
des chaque jeunes à construire son
avenir et aider les enseignants à œuvrer
pour une réelle persévérance scolaire je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
Francis Dubois
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur la situation des
lycées technologiques professionnels et
post-bac qui développe des formations en
alternance par la voix de
l'apprentissage en convention avec les
CFA naturellement le corps enseignant
s'inquiète sur le sujet concilier
considérant qu'il n'y a pas assez de
temps académique néanmoins dans le
budget de ces lycées depuis la dernière
loi sur la formation professionnelle on
se rend compte que le versement
volontaire libre des entreprises sur la
taxe formation continue et la taxe
d'apprentissage
bénéficie de moins en moins à ses lycées
en développant l'apprentissage ces
lycées perçoivent de fait une part de
ces deux taxes pour les apprentis de
l'établissement reversés par les
entreprises qui accueillent leurs élèves
la taxe d'apprentissage est souvent le
seul levier d'investissement conséquent
utilisé par les lycées technologiques
professionnels et post-bac ensuite de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement versé
par les régions aussi afin que ces
lycées dégagent des moyens financiers
plus importants l'éducation nationale
prévoit-elle un développement plus
conséquent et accélération des
programmes d'apprentissage dans la carte
de formation de ces lycées quels sont
les moyens envisagés pour inciter les
directions d'établissements et le corps
enseignant à développer l'offre
d'apprentissage des quotas sont-ils
prévus pour les formations par
l'apprentissage par rapport à la
formation initiale envisage dévoue
également un bonus sur l'octroi de
moyens supplémentaire en dotation
horaire globale par les rectorats je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
vos réponses merci monsieur le député
Jean-Claude Rault
mes excuses nous sommes mal compris donc
oui je voudrais revenir en quelques mots
sur la réforme du lycée professionnel
parce que il ne faut pas accuser les
enseignants de crier au loup parce que
le loup ils l'ont déjà rencontré à
plusieurs reprises sous Monsieur Sarkozy
avec la suppression d'une année
d'enseignement et récemment sous votre
prédécesseur avec un tiers des heures
d'enseignement général qui ont été
retirés donc moi je vous demande un peu
solennellement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous assurer que dans la réforme du
lycée professionnel à venir il n'y aura
pas une minute de moins d'enseignement
général que ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui qui
est déjà en net baisse par rapport à ces
dernières années j'ajoute monsieur le
ministre que peut-être que pour élever
le taux d'emploi à la à l'issue il
faudrait remettre cette 4e année il
faudrait peut-être aussi permettre au
lycéen de suivre la filière de leur
choix enfin et ça effectivement ce
serait une belle réforme du lycée
professionnel que de garantir à chaque
jeune de pouvoir accéder pas trop loin
de chez lui à la filière de son choix je
me joins également à mon collègue qui
vous interrogeait sur 49-3 parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a quand même le
sentiment de de revivre une deuxième
fois une forme de d'attente désespéré à
la Godo
merci Madame la mini madame madame
députée excusez-moi
Frédéric maillot
merci Manon la présidente en préambule
je souhaite savoir Monsieur le Ministre
si vous avez vraiment confirmé avoir mis
en place un groupe de travail sur les
problèmes récurrents de l'affectation
dans l'Hexagone des néo titulaires dans
des académies de tramarines ma question
en elle-même porte sur l'éducation
prioritaire dont la refonte en 2015 a
créé deux catégories de réseau
elle porte plus précisément sur les
frontières entre ces deux catégories qui
ne vont pas toujours de soi et c'est le
cas dans l'école prima de Saint-Denis de
la Réunion l'indice de position sociale
les résultats aux évaluations nationales
ça localisation dans un quartier
prioritaire politique de la ville tout
converge pour que cette école soit
placée en raide plus mais ce n'est pas
le cas depuis qu'elle est rattachée à un
collège dont les caractéristiques
socio-économiques sont plus favorables
ce décalage entre les difficultés
objectifs et les moyens disponibles
mettent à mal la promesse d'égalité des
chances je me fais donc porte-parole de
l'équipe éducative pour vous demander le
classement de l'école prima en raide
plus notamment par le biais d'une
convention
qui mettrait à mal l'éducation de ces
gamins en école dans l'école de Prima
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Caroline parmentier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre notre pays fait face à un
phénomène qui s'accentue celui des
tenues communautariste à l'école
particulièrement détenues islamiques
c'est le déploiement des abayas comme
vous l'indiquiez vous-même le 4 octobre
sur France 2 la parole était désormais
courante de voir des élèves défier
l'école de la République par le port de
tenue confessionnelle l'école publique
doit être un lieu sanctuarisé où le
communautarisme n'a pas sa place lors du
premier trimestre 2022 sur les 627
signalements relatifs à la laïcité 22%
concernait le port de tenue religieuse
ce chiffre serait en hausse de 50% entre
le premier et le second trimestre en
outre combien de signalements n'ont pas
lieu par peur de répercussions de
menaces par souci du pas de vague
monsieur le ministre qu'attendez-vous
pour mettre fin à ses dérives
inquiétantes dont vous êtes conscient et
pourquoi ne pas envisager le port de
l'uniforme dans un souci de brassage
social mais aussi culturel cette mesure
serait de nature à lutter contre le les
amendements portés par leur
rassemblement national vont dans ce sens
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
et je vous rappelle quand même que nous
sommes en audition budgétaire
et donc les questions se portent sur
l'examen du budget et ce serait bien que
chacun ait chacune puisse le respecter
merci beaucoup Céline Calvez
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la mission enseignement
scolaire que nous étudions financent la
scolarisation plus de 12 millions
d'élèves dès la classe de maternelle il
y a ce titre cette hausse historique de
3,7 milliards d'euros de financement ne
se limite pas à l'enseignement public
mais également à l'enseignement privé
l'occasion ici soulignée qui participent
ainsi à la mission de service public qui
est l'enseignement scolaire et que le
système privé est financé
majoritairement par le budget de l'État
le ministère de l'Éducation a publié la
semaine dernière les fichiers détaillés
de l'indice de position sociale par
établissement c'est une première et
c'est indice est fabriqué à partir des
catégories socioprofessionnelles des
parents d'élèves quel constat celui
d'une moindre mixité dans les collèges
privés qui accueille une plus grande
part des familles favorisées vous avez
vous-même rappelé dans un récent
entretien avec le monde que la mixité
sociale était un enjeu fondamental et
que vous attendiez de l'enseignement
privé sous contrat qu'il participe à
cette politique de mixité scolaire nous
pourrions demander un peu plus et votre
citation tout en affirmant bien sûr que
vous étiez sûr que ces établissements
partagent l'objectif de mixité scolaire
certains d'ailleurs le mettre en
pratique ainsi pourriez-vous nous
évoquer les pistes envisagées par le
Ministère afin de permettre de demander
un peu plus pour les mixités sociales
aux établissements privés qui voient
comme le public leur financement par
l'État augmenté de plus de 5%, je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée Laurent est-ce
que negox
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre en 2020 le Conseil d'État
confirmé que la prise en charge
financière des aesh intervenant dure le
temps périscolaire relevé de la
compétence des communes nombre de
collectivités ne semblent pas être au
courant qui leur reviennent de supporter
ce coup et d'organiser le service
certains enfants qui une ESH pour le
temps scolaire se retrouve sans personne
sur le temps périscolaire les parents
ont d'autres choix que de plus les
inscrire à la cantine ou à La Haye comme
je l'ai constaté lors de ma permanence
vendredi dernier à
Saint-Orens-de-Gameville face à cela
votre ministère annonçait en juillet en
juillet 2021 des échanges pour assurer
la coordination de l'ensemble des
acteurs monsieur ministre pouvez-vous
nous informer sur l'état de ces
discussions sur ce sujet et les
solutions apportées aux parents
d'enfants en situation de handicap je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
Rodrigo Arenas
vous pouvez
hop
la présidente merci monsieur le ministre
je trouve ça toujours surprenant que le
rassemble national
œuvre contre les écoles confessionnelles
privées c'est une bonne nouvelle
ma question
relève sur la question des lycées
professionnels
à savoir que la réforme du lycée
professionnel laisse entendre que il y a
une volonté de baisser drastiquement les
cours d'enseignement général pour
notamment pouvoir augmenter les temps de
stage c'est évidemment mécanique en
fonction du temps devant élève
et ça nous fait poser deux questions
indépendamment évidemment de ce que nous
pouvons penser les uns les autres du
bien fondé de cette réforme la première
c'est de savoir ce que deviendront les
enseignants de ces matières
d'enseignement général comme l'anglais
ou le français par exemple la seconde
est de savoir comment vous êtes apeuré
les examens des élèves en effet alors
même qu'il rencontre déjà des
difficultés pour certains à obtenir leur
diplôme avec des notes suffisantes dans
ces disciplines d'enseignement général
et qui sont des matières qui sont
évidemment essentielles à la
compréhension du monde et à pouvoir
lutter contre les fake news et certaines
idées reçues qu'on a y compris entendu
ce soir dans cette commission comment
est-ce qu'il parviendront en ayant
toujours moins d'heures de cours
d'anglais d'histoire ou de français
merci monsieur le député je fais la même
remarque précédemment des questions
budgétaires s'il vous plaît dans une
audition budgétaire Anne-Sophie frigo
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre il y a quelques jours dans ma
circonscription à Reims une rixe d'une
violence inouïe avec latée devant un
lycée impliquant plus une trentaine de
jeunes la francement a débordé à
l'intérieur de l'établissement l'un des
protagonistes à visage d'une bombe
lacrymogène et mettait rapporté qu'un
autre à utiliser un marteau notamment
contre le proviseur adjoint au final
plusieurs élèves ont été blessés la
gravité des faits a profondément marqué
les élèves les parents les professeurs
et l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
je veux une nouvelle fois leur adresser
mon soutien compte tenu de la
multiplication de ces événements il y a
urgence à agir pour refaire de nos
établissements scolaires des sanctuaires
parce que notre pays est gangrené par
l'insécurité il faut une volonté
politique et de véritables moyens
financiers que vous n'avez pas mis dans
votre budget l'État doit œuvrer aux
côtés des collectivités pour garantir la
sécurité aux abords et à l'intérieur des
établissements scolaires cela peut
passer par des caméra de vidéoprotection
mais aussi par l'installation de
tourniquet sans oublier la présence de
force de l'ordre lorsque cela est
malheureusement nécessaire dès lors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple quand avez-vous agir pour assurer
la sécurité de nos concitoyens et de nos
lycéens allez-vous enfin revoir vos
priorités je vous remercie merci madame
la députée Laurent Croisier
oui
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la hausse du budget de
l'éducationale de l'éducation nationale
démontre cette année encore l'ambition
portée par la majorité présidentielle
pour l'éducation notre jeunesse et je
vous en remercie ma question portera sur
l'apprentissage des langues vivantes et
plus particulièrement sur la diminution
du nombre d'élèves choisissant la langue
vivante allemande ce sujet m'interpelle
particulièrement de par l'intérêt de cet
apprentissage dans ma circonscription et
plus généralement dans l'Académie de
Besançon regarde sa proximité et des
enjeux transfrontaliers économiques
culturels et sociaux avec l'Allemagne et
la Suisse il concerne toutefois
l'ensemble du pays tant la France et
l'Allemagne nous des liens forts
l'allemand est la première langue
d'Europe en termes de locuteur pourtant
seule 15% des élèves français
choisissent l'allemand en langue vivante
2 contre 29% en 1995 ajoutons à cela le
nombre de candidats du KPS qui diminuent
72% des postes n'ayant pas été pourvu
cette année face à ce constat quels sont
les mesures envisagées dans ce budget
pour pallier à la situation actuelle et
favoriser l'apprentissage de cette
langue merci monsieur le député Alexis
Corbière
oui monsieur le ministre
très rapidement je veux faire appel en
vous parce que je vous connais à
l'amoureux de l'école que vous êtes de
l'école publique qui refuse son
ubérisation et je vais prendre une
question qui n'a que trop duré la
situation des aesh monsieur le ministre
ça suffit ça fait maintenant cinq ans
pour être responsabilité je la place
dans la continuité de ministres
précédents il n'y a pas véritable
d'action énergique pour régler ce
dossier selon vos propres chiffres de
votre ministère il y a seulement une Ash
pour 4 élèves qui sont en situation de
handicap pourquoi cette réalité 97% des
aesh sans contraint un temps partiel
donc j'irai vite vous avez répondu
généralement soit avec une parole je
vois vous le dire assez confuse que
selon vous la hausse des effectifs n'est
pas la solution alors c'est quoi votre
solution en déplacement dernièrement à
la Réunion vous avez dit qu'il faut
faire un effort pour créer des postes
d'avsh mais quelle est cet effort
concrètement vous avez annoncé la
création de 4000 postes mais quels
moyens comptez-vous prendre pour que ce
soit réellement pourvu enfin je vais
vous dire il est temps de parler statut
rémunération titularisation et je vous
le répète pourquoi ce dossier traîne
pourquoi cela traîne comment accepter
que des aesh soient payés 700 euros
l'ubérisation de l'école ça suffit
monsieur le ministre c'est la question
des aviation que nous jugerons votre
efficacité je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole pour la réponse à
ces questions
je vous remercie
madame la Présidente je vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vais commencer par la question des
décrocheurs scolaires puisque en effet
le nombre de décrocheurs scolaires est
encore trop élevé je vous suis
volontiers même si il est de environ 90
000 jeunes qui 95000 jeunes qui sortent
chaque année sans formation
et sans qualification c'est une baisse
tout de même par rapport à il y a
quelques années où ils étaient 130
000 à 140 000 de mémoire et donc nous
avons il nous faut quand même aller plus
loin le PLF 2023 justement
prévoit des crédits en faveur de la
lutte contre le décrochage ils augment
pour atteindre les
59,8 millions et qui des crédits qui
permettront de financer les dispositifs
qui existent ce qu'on appelle les
dispositifs de retour à l'école il y a
une plateforme en ligne nouvelle chance
et il y a également des plateformes
spécifiques d'appui et de suivi au
décrocheur donc ce sont des dispositifs
relais nous comptons également sur
l'appui d'association qui sont actives
pour repérer et diriger les décrocheurs
mais il est évident qu'il nous faut
inclure cette question des décrocheurs
scolaires dans notre politique générale
et l'augmentation des crédits va dans ce
sens en ce qui concerne la taxe
d'apprentissage monsieur le député
disons pour cette année des objectifs
ambitieux au sein du ministère avec
le recrutement de
1200 1200 apprentis
dans les métiers qui sont les métiers
administratifs techniques
bibliothèque aussi de l'éducation
nationale et également
6600 apprentis en pré professionnels
il faut ajouter à cela l'augmentation
alors 6620 en pré professionnelisation
pardon c'est une augmentation de 17%
entre
2021 et 2022
à propos des lycées professionnels
l'enseignement général je le répète sera
préservé nous pouvons faire mieux en
matière d'enseignement général la
question de la filière de son choix à
mon sens doit être
reformulée ce qui est
utile c'est une filière qui soit une
filière de professionnalisation qui
correspondent aux besoins du marché au
sens large du terme et de ce point de
vue là il y a des filières d'excellence
mais ces filières d'excellence
cohabitent avec des filières qui ne
correspondent plus aux évolutions de
l'économie et donc le choix des filières
doit être aussi déterminée par la
pertinence des filières par rapport à
l'objectif qui est celui de l'emploi
les néo titulaires ultramarins nous en
avons déjà parlé je vous confirme la
création d'un groupe de travail à ce
sujet je me suis entretenu à ce propos
avec de nombreux députés ultramarins et
y compris le président enfin et par
ailleurs le président de Région Serge
les chimie nous avons convenu d'un
groupe de travail de manière à ce que au
mois de mai prochain nous puissions
aboutir à une solution convenable je ne
promets pas des merveilles mais nous
allons faire au mieux avec avec vous si
vous souhaitez participer à ce groupe de
travail la carte j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire à propos de de l'académie de la
Réunion la carte et de celle de
Martinique aussi la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire cette carte a en partie
vieilli puisque ça c'est la dernière
mouture remonte maintenant à 2015 il y a
eu des évolutions importantes d'un point
de vue sociologique et du point de vue
de la de la répartition de la des de
disons des des élèves et puis des
familles et donc il nous faut regarder
cette carte
d'éducation prioritaire et procéder aux
ajustements nécessaires que ce soit dans
l'Hexagone ou bien dans les départements
et académie ultramarines en ce qui
concerne le port de l'uniforme cette
question
[Musique]
n'est pas n'a pas fait alors on peut le
dire de deux manières d'abord on
remarquant que le port de l'uniforme
existe dans certaines académies en
outre-mer les élèves
ultramarins portent un uniforme uniforme
c'est un polo de couleurs avec le sigle
de leur lycée et il s'emporte très bien
d'ailleurs comme j'ai pu m'en assurer
auprès d'eux récemment deuxième remarque
préalable
rien interdit dans le code de
l'éducation à ce que un chef
d'établissement puisse prendre une
initiative de ce genre il n'y a pas
d'interdiction actuelle du port de
l'uniforme mais il n'y a pas de consigne
national je suis disposé à ce qu'un
groupe de travail si vous souhaitiez
d'aventure travailler sur cette question
se penche sur le sujet mais il faut
avancer avec des éléments tangibles il y
a une étude britannique qui est paru et
qui a été mise en valeur par le Conseil
scientifique de l'éducation nationale
qui porte sur cette question et qui
conclut à plusieurs éléments nuancés
mais qui indique que la question du
niveau scolaire n'est absolument pas
touchée par le port de l'uniforme ça n'a
aucun effet il y a des effets qui
peuvent être je vous la fournirai si
vous le souhaitez
des effets qui peuvent être discutés sur
les questions de d'appartenance et de
sentiment d'appartenance à
l'établissement
donc je ne ferme pas la porte à cette
question mais je demande à avoir des
éléments tangibles qui permettraient de
se prononcer sur sur la question
à propos du pardon on me signale vous
vraiment je vous présente mes plates
excuses c'est que au fur et à mesure je
note les questions mais je ne note pas
les le nom des orateurs donc ne prenez
pas ça pour une mauvaise manière à votre
égard je vous prie de de m'en excuser je
ferais mieux la prochaine fois sachez
que on avait convenu monsieur le
ministre que vous fassiez des réponses
groupées par rapport aux thématiques
donc c'est pour ça mais effectivement la
prochaine fois on vous je ferais mieux
la prochaine fois
voilà tout à fait non mais c'était d'un
coq c'était d'un comacor donc c'est pour
ça c'était pour dédouaner le ministre
qui où on avait décidé d'un commun
accord que ce serait des réponses
groupées donc effectivement vous ne
citez pas le nom de nos collègues à
chaque fois mais je pense qu'il se
reconnaîtront dans les différentes
interventions et dans vos réponses je
vous remercie de votre indulgence et de
votre amabilité madame la Présidente à
propos de l'enseignement oui nous avons
publié donc toutes les données IPS en
Open Data c'était d'ailleurs une demande
qui émanait du tribunal administratif
mais nous avons plutôt que de les
distiller une par une nous avons décidé
de les publier complètement et en effet
j'ai indiqué dans l'entretien auquel
vous faisiez allusion que l'enseignement
privé sous contrat qui est financé par
l'État en tout cas du point de vue des
enseignants que l'on pourrait attendre
plus et demander plus de l'enseignement
privé sous contrat j'ai eu la SAT
d'ailleurs depuis que je me suis exprimé
en ce sens d'avoir des retours de la
part de chefs d'établissement de ces de
ces établissements qui sont tout à fait
disposés à échanger sur le sujet nous
allons voir comment procéder il y a
plusieurs pistes je ne veux pas
m'avancer trop sur le sujet mais il est
clair que on ne peut pas exclure
l'enseignement privé sous contrat de la
question de la mixité scolaire à
laquelle nous sommes nous sommes
attachés à propos des
aesh là encore la question est revenue
d'abord monsieur le député la question
des avsh personne ne réclame un aesh par
enfant en situation
de handicap ou enfants a besoin
particulier il y a des situations
extrêmement variées parmi 430 000
enfants à besoins particuliers certains
ont effectivement besoin d'un avsh il
n'y a aucun doute là-dessus mais
d'autres n'ont pas nécessairement besoin
d'un accompagnement à un usage faute de
quoi il nous faudrait engager 300 000
aesh ça représenterait avec les 130 000
existants on aurait un aesh pour deux
enseignants et j'aime mieux vous dire
que la hausse du budget du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale ce serait pas 6,5
pour 100 mais au-delà de cette question
strictement budgétaire les besoins les
associations elles-mêmes de parents que
nous avons consulté au mois de juillet
dernier ne réclame pas un aesh par
enfant a besoin particulier il faut des
avsh il y a aucun doute là-dessus ça je
vous suis il faut améliorer la situation
des AEH je vous suis il faut améliorer
la rémunération des aesh on y travaille
avec un bulletin de paie et avec le
périscolaire et le scolaire je vous suit
là dessus on y travaille c'est un mais
c'est une tâche extrêmement difficile
parce que nous ne sommes pas les seules
opérateurs en la matière on a les
maisons du handicap et puis on a aussi à
trouver à former les aesh 4000 ça n'est
pas rien j'étais à la Réunion on dispose
encore d'un petit volant d'Ash et donc
on puisse dans ce petit dans cette
petite réserve nationale d'Ash en
particulier pour les situations les plus
difficiles je suis bien conscient de la
difficulté des situations mais nous
avons aussi parfois le sentiment de
courir après la marée si j'ose dire et
donc ce que je dis et d'ailleurs c'est
ce que les représentants des maisons
départementales du handicap disent
eux-mêmes c'est que il faut aussi penser
à la variété des réponses possibles un
aesh collectif pour plusieurs enfants a
besoin particulier ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas par défaut forcément ça n'est pas
parce qu'on n'a pas
individuel c'est parce que parfois c'est
effectivement la bonne solution donc il
faut regarder la variété écouter les
associations qui
effectivement réclame plus d'avsh mais
pas que des ash il y a toute une gamme
c'est pour ça que nous avons besoin de
mettre à plat les choses plutôt que de
créer des postes d'Osh au sens le plus
cumulatif du terme à propos de
l'enseignement de l'allemand il est vrai
que le pourcentage d'élèves germaniste
décroît alors c'est pas spectaculaire
puisqu'on était à 14,8%
en 2020 on est à part dans la 14,8%
aujourd'hui c'était à la rentrée 2021 et
on était à 15,7 en 2019 mais
paradoxalement la situation est encore
plus difficile pour le recrutement de
professeurs d'allemand parce qu'il y a
eu un effet malthusien en quelque sorte
avec une baisse les élèves germanistes
mais une baisse encore plus nette aussi
des
des concours de recrutement en tout cas
des postes au concours de recrutement de
professeurs d'allemand alors ce que nous
préparons c'est une un rebond ou une
nouvelle stratégie pour la langue
allemande avec notre partenaire avec
l'Allemagne il va y avoir un séminaire
d'ailleurs à ce sujet bientôt puisque du
côté de l'Allemagne il y a des
difficultés à peu près équivalentes pour
la langue française et donc on a de quoi
échangé à ce sujet afin de redynamiser
la langue allemande c'est pas simplement
une question de post de professeur c'est
aussi une question d'échange avec des
classes et avec des villes allemandes
d'attractivité du métier
et de dispositifs bilingues allemands
français nous y sommes nous y sommes
très attentif en ce qui concerne les
postes de professeur nous avons un
mauvais rendement du concours de capes
et d'agrégation puisque nous avons plus
de poste que de professeurs recrutés et
donc là on a une difficulté c'est celle
d'un vivier qui sait tari avec les ans
nous serions ravis de recruter plus de
professeurs d'allemand et nous avons
effectivement des difficultés des
difficultés de poste j'en profite par
ces incises pour rappeler que les
difficultés que nous avons du point de
vue
des postes sont des difficultés de ce
qu'on appelle des BNP fondamentalement
c'est à dire des blocs de moyens
provisoires c'est-à-dire ce sont des non
pas des postes entiers mais ce sont des
bouts
par-ci par là d'heures il manque quatre
heures d'économie gestion dans tel lycée
il manque deux heures de portugais dans
tel autre lycée il manque des heures
mais ce sont ce qu'on appelle des BNP ce
sont pas des ETP ce sont des BNP et
c'est ça qui est très difficile à
remplir ce sens et cases qui sont
extrêmement difficiles à remplir et je
suis bien conscient que pour les
familles et les élèves lorsqu'ils
montrent que 4 heures d'économie gestion
c'est une c'est un vrai problème mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il manque un poste
au sens plein du terme parce qu'on est
obligé d'éclater les services sur
plusieurs établissements et c'est une
difficulté notamment dans certaines
zones avec des établissements distants
entre eux par exemple le sud de la
Seine-et-Marne avec des lycées distants
et donc des enseignants qui sont obligés
de faire des kilométrages importants
pour pouvoir
faire leur service
voilà ce que je voulais dire